GOOD MORNING WE ARE GOING TO
BE CALLING THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
TO ORDER -- LET ME JUST FIRST
START OFF BY WELCOMING ALL
THE NEW MEMBERS TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
NOW IS AT THIRTY TWO MEMBERS
WHICH IS THE LARGEST BUDGET
COMMITTEE WE'VE HAD AND -- OR
DOING A LITTLE BIT OF FUN AYE
CONFIGURING THIS ROOM TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN ACCOMMODATE
ALL ARE ALL OUR MEMBERS HAVING
SAID THAT WERE VERY -- EXCITED
TO WELCOME OUR NEW FOLKS FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HERE
TODAY -- OBVIOUSLY MANY OF US
WATCH THE GOVERNOR UNVEILED
HIS PROPOSAL FOR THE BUDGET
A FEW WEEKS AGO -- IT'S VERY
EXCITING TO SEE A PROPOSAL
THAT INCORPORATED MUCH OF THE
LEGISLATIVE THINKING THAT WE'VE
HAD BOTH FROM THE SENATE AS
WELL AS FROM THE ASSEMBLY OF
THE LAST FEW YEARS -- ISSUES
THAT HAVE NOT REALLY GOTTEN AS
MUCH ATTENTION AS WE WOULD HAVE
LIKE WHETHER YOU WORK EARLY
EDUCATION WHEN THERE IS AN
HEALTH CARE OR E.
I. T. C. -- MANY OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE AS A AS A BODY HAD
BEEN CHAMPING SO IT'S VERY
EXCITING TO HEAR THAT AND
WE WILL BE HEARING THAT --
PROPOSAL VERY VERY SHORTLY --
AS YOU KNOW TODAY'S HEARING
IS THE FIRST OF PROBABLY OVER
ONE HUNDRED HEARINGS -- AS
A FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE WE
KNOW THAT WE DON'T REALLY DO
THE WORK HERE THEY HAPPEN IN
THE FIVE SUBCOMMITTEES SO I
DO IN ADVANCE ONE OF -- THANK
THE FIVE SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS
FOR REALLY ON TAKING TAKING
ON THE TASK OF DISSECTING THE
BUDGET AND REALLY DISCUSSING
THE VARIOUS SUBSTANTIVE ISSUES
-- FOR THE PUBLIC I KNOW THERE
IS SOME CONCERN ABOUT THEIR
OPPORTUNITY FOR INPUT TODAY --
TRUST ME THERE'S OVER A HUNDRED
DIFFERENT HEARINGS WE ARE HAPPY
TO HAVE A ROBUST AND VERY --
SUSPECT ACCESS FULL DEBATE
IN EACH OF THOSE SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARINGS REALLY MOVING FORWARD
-- LET ME ALSO JUST THINK MY MY
VICE CHAIR MISTER OBERNOLTE --
FOR REALLY HIS HIS LEADERSHIP
AND AND REALLY HAS PARTNERSHIP
IN LEADING THIS COMMITTEE AND
JUST WANT TO TURN OVER TO HIM
FOR FOR SOME COMMENTS I'D LIKE
TO JOIN THE CHAIR IN THANKING
EVERYONE FOR SERVING THIS
YEAR ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
I CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT
THE WORK THAT WE DO HERE
IS REALLY AMONGST THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT WE DO
IN THE LEGISLATURE THE DIPPING
UP OVER A HUNDRED AND FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL
FUND SPENDING SO CONSEQUENTLY
I THINK THAT YOUR SERVICE ON
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE GIVES YOU
THE BIGGEST OPPORTUNITY THAT
YOU'LL HAVE IN THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAKE A POSITIVE IMPACT
FOR THE CONSTITUENTS THAT
YOU REPRESENT SO -- I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD
WORK AND DEDICATION AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH ALL OF YOU AS WE CRAFT
THE TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY BUDGET
THANK YOU WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL TING OBERNOLTE
ARAMBULA BLOOM HERE BRO TO
UBER FONG FRAZIER GALLAGHER
GARCIA JONES SAWYER LACKEY
THE MOUNT MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN O'DONNELL
PATTERSON RAMOS RAY S.
REVERSE RUBIO STONE WEBER
WICKS WOULD PRESENT COULD
YOU CALL MR MCCARTY PARTY
WITH THAT WILL MOVE TO THE
FIRST ACTION WHICH IS TO
ADOPT THE COMMITTEE RULES
THE COMMITTEE RULES HAD A
FEW MINOR TECHNICAL CHANGES
COULD I HAVE A MOTION THE
MOTION A SECOND I'M SECRETARY
COULD YOU CALL THE ROLL TING
OBERNOLTE ARAMBULA BLOOM
WROTE TO UBER COOPER I FONG
FONG AYE FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA
JONES SAWYER LACKEY LOW MOAN
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MATHIS
AYE MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE MULLIN
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI AYE
NAZARIAN O'DONNELL O'DONNELL
AYE PATTERSON RAMOS FROM
ASIDE RADIUS REASSIGN REAVIS
RIVERSIDE RUBIO RUBIO AYE STONE
AYE AYE STONE AYE WEBER WICKS
WICKS I WOULD WHAT I THANK YOU
WILL PUT THOSE ROLES ON CALL
FOR FOR THEIR ADOPTION FOR
THEIR -- VOTES OUT WITH THAT
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO ART MID
YEAR BUDGET PACKAGE WE HAVE TO
-- TWO BILLS AB SEVENTY TWO A.
B. SEVENTY THREE AND WILL
LAST FOR DEPARTMENT MINUS TWO
PERCENT WELCOME THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M GRATEFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
WITH YOU MY NAME IS VAGUE THIS
ONE OFTEN AND I SERVE AS CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR BUDGET
ACT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I WANT TO MAKE TWO POINTS
ABOUT THE EARLY ACTION PACKAGE
THAT'S HERE BEFORE YOU -- THE
FIRST IS THAT THIS IS REALLY
AN EMERGENCY PACKAGE IT DEALS
WITH ISSUES LIKE WILD FIRES
EMERGENCY RESPONSE IMMIGRATION
AND THE SITUATION AT THE
BORDER AS WELL AS DRINKING
WATER EMERGENCIES THESE ARE
ALL ISSUES THAT AS YOU KNOW
AFFECT THE CORE COMPETENCIES
OF GOVERNMENT AND SO WE WANTED
TO MAKE SURE ARE WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU THAT WE COULD PUT
FORWARD A PACKAGE EVEN THOUGH
SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS ARE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
-- THAT WE HOPE TO ENACT WITH
LOOK LEGISLATIVE COOPERATION
JUNE WE REALIZE THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULDN'T WAIT
THAT ON ALL THESE ISSUES WE
SHOULD ACTUALLY ACT RIGHT NOW
THE SECOND POINT I WANT TO
MAKE ABOUT THIS PACKAGE IS THAT
AS ALL OF YOU KNOW -- IT CAME
TOGETHER VERY QUICKLY -- THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS TEAM HAD SOME
IDEAS -- WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE ASSEMBLY STAFF AS
WELL AS THE SENATE STAFF AT ALL
REALLY CAME FORWARD IN THE LAST
WEEK SO I'M REALLY GRATEFUL
TO CHRISTIAN GRIFFITH NICOLE
BASS CLASSES -- AND CHASE
INSISTING THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE
FOR HELPING TO CLOSE THIS DEAL
LAST WEEK AND GET IT READY
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION TODAY
SO WHAT'S IN THIS EARLY BUT
-- EARLY ACTION PACKAGE THERE
REALLY TWO ITEMS BEFORE YOU
THERE IS ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
TWO WHICH IS AMENDING THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THAT WAS PASSED LAST JUNE --
AND THEN THERE'S THE TRAILER
BILL ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
THREE SO I'LL GO THROUGH EACH
OF THOSE IN TURN THE FIRST ITEM
I WANTED DISCUSSING ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY TWO IS THE
PROPERTY TAX BACK FILL THIS IS
FOR AND WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
THIS JUST BEFORE THE HEARING
THIS IS TO BACK FILL COUNTIES
AND OTHER LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
FOR PROPERTY TAX LOSSES THAT
OCCURRED AS A RESULT OF THE
FIRES THAT HAPPENED LAST
NOVEMBER WE ARE PROPOSING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH ALL OF YOU
ATTACK FULL FOR ANY PROPERTY
TAX LOSSES FOR BUTTE COUNTY
LAKE COUNTY LOS ANGELES COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY ORANGE COUNTY
SHASTA COUNTY AND SISKIYOU
COUNTY FOR THE FIVE OF THOSE
COUNTIES -- WE'RE PROPOSING
TO BACK FILL FOR ANY LOSSES
INCURRED IN THIS BUDGET YEAR
WITH INITIALLY PROPOSED DOING
SO IN NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET BUT
WE THOUGHT GIVEN THE PRESSURES
THAT NINETIES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE UNDER THAT THERE'S NO
REASON TO WAIT AND WE CAN DO
THIS RIGHT NOW AND FINALLY
FOR BUTTE COUNTY AND FOR LAKE
COUNTY GIVEN THE PARTICULAR
DEVASTATION THAT THOSE COUNTY
SEVEN YARD WE'RE PROPOSING A
THREE YEAR PROPERTY TAX BACK
STILL THAT'S NOT ONLY FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR BUT FOR THE YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
AND FOR THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS YOU
KNOW UNDER PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT THE SCHOOL SHARE OF ANY
LOSS TO THE PROPERTY TAX LOSS
IS BACK FILLED AUTOMATICALLY BY
THE STATE UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION BUT FOR ALL
THE OTHER IMPORTANT PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES THAT PROPERTY
TAXES FIND WITHOUT THIS BACK
FAIL COUNTIES ANOTHER LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE SUFFERING
A LOSS AT THE VERY TIME WHEN
THEY'RE COPING WITH THE AFTER
EFFECTS OF THESE FIRES -- SO
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY
OF THE ADMINISTRATION I KNOW
IT'S AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY
AT SO MANY MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND WE WANTED TO
GET THAT MOVING RIGHT AWAY
THE SECOND ITEM AB SEVENTY TWO
THAT I WANT TO BRING TO YOUR
ATTENTION IS IN THE BROADER
AREA OF EMERGING EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS WHAT WE'VE SEEN
BOTH WITH THIS MOST RECENT
FIRE SEASON AS WELL AS THE
FIRES BEFORE THEN IS THAT
BUILDING COMMUNITY RESILIENCY
ESPECIALLY AMONG VULNERABLE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS THAT
INCLUDE SENIORS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND OTHERS WHO
REALLY BEAR THE BRUNT OF ANY
EMERGENCY EVACUATION OR OTHER
SITUATION I'M REALLY NEED OUR
HELP AND THAT MEANS BOTH AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL SO WE'RE PROPOSING FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS -- IN ONE TIME
FUNDING THAT WE HAD INITIALLY
SLATED IN OUR BUDGET BUT WE
WANT TO GET OUT THE DOOR RIGHT
NOW AND WE DIVIDED INTO TWO
BUCKETS THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
WOULD GO TO THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH INTO CAL
VOLUNTEERS TO BEGIN A STATEWIDE
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS CAMPAIGN
TO BUILD RESILIENCY AND THESE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
AND MAKING SURE IN PARTICULAR
WITH SMALL NORMAL POPULATIONS
WERE REACHING THE PEOPLE
WHO WE NEED TO REACH SO THAT
EVERYONE IS PREPARED BECAUSE
WE DON'T KNOW WHEN THE NEXT
EMERGENCY WILL CALM THE SECOND
BUCKET OF THAT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH WOULD GO TO THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
BUT WOULD REALLY BE DESIGNED
TO FLOW AS GRANTS TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE SEEKING
TO SOLVE THESE ISSUES ON THEIR
OWN AND BUILD RESILIENCY OFF
OF LOCAL LEVEL AND SO I'M HAPPY
TO TALK ABOUT BOTH PORTIONS
OF THOSE THE THIRD PACKAGE
UP THIRD ITEM OF THIS PACKAGE
THAT I WANT TO BRING TO YOUR
ATTENTION IS A TEN MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND LOAN TO
SECOND WHICH IS THE STATE
EMERGENCY TELEPHONE NUMBER
ACCOUNT THIS IS THE ACCOUNT
THAT THE STATE GENERAL USES TO
FIND IMPROVEMENTS TO OUR NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM AND MAKING SURE
THAT IN AN EMERGENCY PEOPLE
PEOPLE CAN CONTACT THE NINE
ONE ONE OFFICE AND THEN WHEN
THOSE NINE ONE ONE CENTERS
ARE EVACUATED AS WE SAW IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE SITUATION AT
THE ORACLE DAMN TWO YEARS AGO
THOSE EMERGENCY CALLS CAN BE
REROUTED AND MAKING SURE THAT
AN EMERGENCY PEOPLE CAN REACH
THE PEOPLE THAT THEY NEED TO
REACH IN GOVERNMENT AND AS WE
DISCUSSED THAT OF COURSE IS
A CORE COMPETENCY TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IS CERTAINLY NOT ENOUGH
TO MOVE US TO A NEXT GENERATION
NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM THAT WE
ALL KNOW WE NEED TO BUILD
-- BUT WE'RE HOPING -- AS WE
DISCUSSED WITH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE HOW WE'RE GONNA
MAKE THOSE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WE CAN START RIGHT NOW WITH THE
EMERGENCY NEEDS THAT WE HAVE
TO BUILD REDUNDANT REDUNDANCIES
INTO OUR MICROWAVE NETWORK
AND MAKING SURE THAT WHATEVER
THE NEXT NEXT EMERGENCY CALMS
THOSE REDUNDANCIES ARE THERE
SO THAT OUR NETWORK IS MORE
SECURE THE FOURTH ITEM I WANT
TO BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION
IN THIS PACKAGE -- SURROUNDS
IMMIGRATION -- MANY OF US ARE
AWARE OF IT THE CRISIS AT THE
BORDER AND SHELTERS THAT ARE
RUN BY NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN PARKED IN FUNDED
BY STATE FUNDING ARE BEING
OVERWHELMED BY THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE COME THROUGH
THOSE AREAS OFTEN STAYING FOR
JUST A DAY OR TWO BEFORE THEY
CONNECT WITH OTHER PEOPLE
IN THE STATE BUT IT IS A
HUMANITARIAN ISSUE THAT NEEDS
ARE ASSISTANCE I HAVE THE
GOVERNOR HAS HEARD FROM MANY
OF YOU AND MANY MEMBERS OF
YOUR STAFF HAS TRAVELED DOWN
TO THE BORDER UNDERSTANDS THAT
THIS IS A PRIORITY AND FOR
IN -- FOR THE FUNDING FOR THE
BORDER THIS IS MONEY THAT NEEDS
TO GO OUT THE DOOR RIGHT NOW
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
OF THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED FOR IMMIGRATION RAPID
RESPONSE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IS IN THE CURRENT BUDGET YEAR
AND WE EXPECT IT SOON IF AND
WHEN THIS PACKAGES ENACTED
SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS OF
THAT AMOUNT WILL FLOW OUT
THE DOOR RIGHT AWAY GREAT
THANK YOU CAN WE SEE THIRTY
QUESTIONS ON AB SEVENTY TWO
THE QUESTIONS WHICH GOT JUST
A COMMENT ASIDE YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY REPRESENT -- PARADISE
IN THE AREA THAT'S BEEN
AFFECTED BY THE CAMPFIRE -- NO
IT'S BEEN MIA JUST REAL OTHER
DEVASTATION THERE AND -- YOU
KNOW THE COMMITTEES ARE TRYING
TO RECOVER -- AND I'VE ACTUALLY
SOME OF OUR -- COLLEAGUES WHEN
VISITED -- A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
AND YOU WANT THEY WANT TO SEE
IS WE HAVE A WHOLE TOWN THAT
REALLY HAS AND YOU KNOW NONE
OF THE OTHER REVENUE SUPPORT
THAT WAS TRADITIONALLY THEIR
PROPERTY TAXES THE SALES
TAX ALL THAT IS REALLY BEEN
DECIMATED AND SO I I JUST WANT
TO SAY I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
-- CHAIRMAN -- AND COMMITTEE
STAFF -- ADJACENT SYSTEM IN
THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE EVERYBODY
REALLY COMING TOGETHER -- TO
INSURE THAT WE CAN DO THIS TO
PROVIDE THAT CERTAINTY HE KNOWS
HE'S COMMUNITIES ARE TRYING
TO REBUILD HAVING THAT YOU
KNOW STABLE FUNDING SOURCE IS
GOING TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT
SO I APPRECIATE THAT ALSO THE
THERE'S I THINK WE MAY BE A
LITTLE TOO BUT THE FUNDING IN
THERE FOR ALSO THE REBUILDING
WELL AND SEPTIC SYSTEMS I MEAN
THIS WAS A COMMUNITY THAT YOU
KNOW RELIED MOSTLY ON SEPTIC
AND SO YOU TO THE EXTENT THE
INSURANCE PROCEEDS DOESN'T
COVER THAT -- WE'RE GONNA NEED
ASSISTANCE WITH THAT -- YOU
KNOW FOR PEOPLE AS THEY REBUILT
SO -- YOU APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK HAS BEEN PUT AND PUT IT
ON THIS I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER GARDNER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
OBVIOUSLY ARE -- AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE BEEN DOING TO REALLY
HELP THOSE RESIDENTS UP THERE
DOCTOR WHAT YES SIR THANK YOU
-- FIRST OF ALL -- I FULLY
SUPPORT THE THE BACK FILL FOR
THE COUNTIES THAT YOU YOU'VE
MENTIONED -- WHAT LAKE COUNTY
IT'S GONE TO A PARTICULAR BUTTE
COUNTY A PRETTY HORRIFIC I
HAPPEN TO REPRESENT MENDOCINO
IN CINEMA COUNTY AND --
GLARINGLY OBVIOUS IS A LACK OF
-- CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR THE
BACK FILL FOR THOSE TWO COUNTY
SO I'M CURIOUS CAN YOU EXPLAIN
WHY YOU'RE NOT WE LOST OVER
FIVE THOUSAND HOMES ALONE IN
CINEMA COUNTY -- IT'S GOING TO
TAKE YEARS FOR THOSE TO REBUILD
-- AND MENDOCINO COUNTY LOST
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR
HOMES I BELIEVE THAT NUMBER
MAY BE UP BUT AND I KNOW THAT
AB SO I'M IT'S JUST YOU LIST
OF ALL THE COUNTIES AND TO THE
COUNTY IN WHAT THEY WANT COUNTY
THERE WAS ABSOLUTELY IMPACTED
SERIOUSLY IS NOT ON THE LIST
AND THEN AND THEN MENDOCINO
COUNTY ISN'T AS WELL SO CAN
YOU EXPLAIN SOME OF THAT MISTER
BLOOM AT ON YOU CAN ANSWER BOTH
QUESTIONS THE SAME QUESTION
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE SIDE
OF THE WALLS THE FIRE YES UP
SO LOS ANGELES COUNTY -- SO
THE FIRES THAT OCCURRED LAST
NOVEMBER ME ALL THE AFFECTED
COUNTIES WE ARE PROPOSING
A BACK SALE I WILL GET BACK
TO YOU ON THE MENDOCINO
AND AT SOME COLLEAGUES FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OR HERE AS WELL SO LET ME
MAKE SURE I GET THE DETAIL
RIGHT WE HAVE A COLLEAGUE
WALKING UP AS WE SPEAK YES
GOOD MORNING CHRIS GOOD
MORNING CRYSTAL DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE -- AS SOON AS WE
RECEIVE INFORMATION FROM IN
THE SCENE AND WE WILL BUILD OUT
NUMBERS NUMBER THE DIRECT OUT
AND WE JUST HAVEN'T RECEIVED
INFORMATION YET THE AND --
WE WERE KERN COUNTY ARE FOR
CONTROLLERS TO REACH OUT TO
US ON A FLOW BASIS WITH THEIR
LOSS INFORMATION WILL BUILD
THAT INTO THE -- SPRING FINANCE
LETTER PROCESS IF NECESSARY
AND CINEMA COUNTY IN CINEMAS
WELL BOTH LOS ANGELES YES FOR
ANY -- FOR ANY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FIRE LOSSES YES
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ON DOCTOR WOULD FOLLOW THEM
AND KEEP BEFORE YOU GO HE SAID
BEFORE BEFORE EIGHTEEN FIRE
LOSSES YOU SAID CORRECT THAT
IS CORRECT FOR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN SO THE THE LOSSES
FOR TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN OR
NOT UNDER CONSIDERATION -- THE
GOVERNOR'S ON I'M SORRY THE
BUDGET ACT DOES PROVIDE THE
-- TO YOUR BACK FILL FOR --
FOR CINEMA FOR TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND FOR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
YOU'RE PROPOSING A THREE YEAR
BACK FILL FOR OTHER COUNTIES
AND ON I BELIEVE THAT WAS IN
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
AS ON MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED
THAT THEY'VE BEEN DEVASTATED
THEY'VE LOST -- SIGNIFICANT
NUMBERS OF PROPERTIES
OKAY AT AT THAT I WOULD JUST
ARGUE AS AS CINEMA COUNTY
MAKES HIM BUT THANK YOU
THE COMMENTS FROM THE DÍAS
ANY MEMBERS OF PUBLIC IN
FAVOR OF AB SEVENTY TWO
SURE TING IN MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL SHOT YOU'RE INTO WE
HEAR ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTIES
OF BUTTE CINNAMON SHASTA I
WANT TO BEGIN MY COMMENTS
THIS MORNING BY THINKING THAT
COMMITTEE AND THE NEW SOME
ADMINISTRATION FOR MOVING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE FORWARD --
AS YOU KNOW OUR COMMUNITIES
WERE DEVASTATED BY STRING
OF WILDFIRES IN OUR STATE IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN -- THIS MEASURE
TAKES IMPORTANT STEPS TOWARDS
MAKING OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
RESIDENTS HOLE WE SUPPORT AB
SEVENTY TWO -- BUT I'D LIKE
TO CALL OUT OUR STRONG SUPPORT
AND THINGS FOR THE FOLLOWING
-- LINE ITEMS A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AS WAS MENTIONED FOR
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS --
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGNS
FOCUS ON CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS THE
TEN MILLION DOLLARS FROM --
MURDERS HE BELIEVED GRANTS
THE FUNDING WELL REPLACEMENT
SEPTIC SYSTEM REPLACEMENT AND
PERMANENT CONNECTIONS TO THE
PUBLIC SYSTEMS ON NOTE THAT
THE TOWN OF PARADISE IS THE
LARGEST MUNICIPALITY WEST
OF THE MISSISSIPPI THE STILL
RELIES ON SEPTIC TANKS IN THE
SIXTY FOUR POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR PROPERTY TAX BACK
FILL FOR TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES OF
FINALLY ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
OF VIEW -- I WANT TO THANK THE
THE COMMITTEE AND THERE WERE
NINE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
WHICH TOWARD THE CAMPFIRE AND
THE NEW SOME ADMINISTRATION
FOR RECOGNIZING THE SEVERITY
OF THE CAMPFIRE IN THE ENORMOUS
TASK THAT LIES BEFORE US IN
REBUILDING WE ARE DRIVE UP
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRISTY
ABOUT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS REPRESENTING
THE MEN AND WOMEN THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE ON THAT
FIRE SCENE AND MANY OTHERS
THAT WERE MENTIONED HERE THIS
MORNING -- WE APPLAUD THIS
RAPID WRIST RAPID ACTION AND
AND A TO QUOTE MY PRESIDENT
BRIAN RICE THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS HE
SAID WE CAN'T EVER EVER LET
THIS HAPPEN AGAIN WHEN ENTIRE
TOWN IS HE RACED OFF THE MAP
AND SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR QUICK
ACTION AND ONE STRONG SUPPORT
CHRIS RESPONSES A TRAILER THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR
-- PUTTING INTO OUR MONEY
FOR IMMIGRATION SERVICES
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE BORDER
SITUATION -- WE ARE ONE --
ONE CALIFORNIA GRANT TN WE
PROVIDE LEGAL SERVICES SOME
OF OUR MEMBERS FROM OUR LEGAL
TEAM DID ASSIST OUR PARTNERS
AT THE BORDER REGION -- WHEN
THE CRISIS I HONESTLY HAPPENED
AND CONTINUES TO GO ON --
TODAY -- THEREFORE WITH THE
REPORTS I RECEIVED BACK FROM
OUR LEGAL TEAM ON THE GROUND
-- THIS MONEY IS ABSOLUTELY
-- NEEDED AND IT SHOWS THAT
CALIFORNIA UNDERSTANDS -- WHAT
IS NEEDED HERE ARE TO BORDER
NO I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION WE
SERVE RURAL FARMER COMMUNITIES
WE APPRECIATE THE FUNDING
ESPECIALLY THAT GOES TO
OUR FORMAL POPULATIONS TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT ARE
IMPACTING ON SO LEVY EIGHT THE
HARNESS I'VE GONE ON THROUGH
THESE EMERGENCY SITUATIONS
SPECIFICALLY FAIRLY FOUNDATION
IS A ONE CALIFORNIA STAKEHOLDER
AND WE APPLAUD THE EMERGENCY
FUNDING FOR IMMIGRATION RELATED
SERVICES THAT ARE BADLY NEEDED
THAT'S OCCURRING TRI STATE
IN THE CALIFORNIA'S LEADING
AS A COMPASSIONATE STATE IN
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES OF
SETTING AN EXAMPLE FOR ALL
OUR INDIVIDUALS REGARDLESS
OF STATUS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
A MISTER CHAIRMAN CLIFF
BURGUNDY HAVE AS YOU SHAMLI
SERVICES OF SAN DIEGO WANT
TO THANK THE GOVERNOR AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR
THE LEADERSHIP IN DEALING
WITH THE IMMIGRATION CRISIS
THE BORDER URGE YOUR SUPPORT
AS SPENCER SAXON THE WELCOME
GROUP ON BEHALF OF -- CATHOLIC
CHARITIES WE APPRECIATE
ALL THE HELP LEADERSHIP
ON THIS BILL AND WE --
OR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
NATION ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
WE ALSO WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND THE COMMITTEE ON THE
SWIFT ACTION THANK YOU
THE SHUTTLE GOV ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNT OF SAN DIEGO WE'RE
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY TWO
AND WE APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOGNITION OF THE IMMIGRATION
CRISIS AT OUR BORDERS WE ARE
SPECIFICALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE FIVE MILLION THAT IS GOING
OUT TO HELP THIS POPULATION
WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER
ALLOWING PUBLIC AGENCIES
TO ALSO BE REIMBURSED FOR
ANY MONIES EXPENDED WHAT'S
POPULATION WE APPLAUD THE
EFFORTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BEING UNDERTAKEN BY THE NON
PROFITS WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT
MISTER CHAIR MARK FENSTER MAKE
RUN HAVE THIS NUMBER COUNTY
WATER AGENCY SOME WATERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY TWO --
UNFORTUNATELY WE ALL WE KNOW
ALL TOO WELL HOW IMPORTANT
-- PUBLIC AWARENESS IS FOR
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AND
SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE OF
OF THAT ITEM IN PARTICULAR
IN THIS PACKAGE THANK YOU
KELLY BROOK SOME BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF VENTURA -- WE
OR THE SIDE OF THE -- THOMAS
FIRE IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
ON THE WHEEL THE FIRE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I DID NOT
HEAR THE DRUG COUNTY MENTIONED
AS ONE OF THE COUNTIES THAT
WOULD BE GETTING -- PROPERTY
TAX BACK FILLS I JUST WANT TO
PUT A PLUG IN FOR THAT WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF -- THE BACKFILL
FOR THE COUNTIES AFFECTED BY
FIRE STICK YOU THANK YOU ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC -- ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN OPPOSITION TO A.
B. SEVENTY TWO
OKAY SEE NINE CAN I GET
A MOTION TO DO PASS AS
AMENDED FOR AB SEVENTY TWO
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
COULD YOU CALL WILL TING TING
AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM
BLOOM AYE BRO CHIU COOPER
COOPER AYE FONG FONG AYE
FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA CHRISSY
I'D JONES SAWYER LACKEY LACKEY
AYE LIMÓN MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE MULLIN MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI EIN IS AREA AND
I O'DONNELL O'DONNELL AYE
PATTERSON PATTERSON I RAMOS
FROM AS I RADIUS RADIUS I
REAVIS REAVIS AYE RUBIO RUBIO
AYE STONE WEBER WICKS I WICKS
I WOULD WHAT AYE AYES TWENTY
FOUR NO ZERO THANK YOU LET'S
GO ON TO -- AB SEVENTY THREE
GREAT THANK YOU ON AB SEVENTY
THREE THERE TO PROVISIONS
-- THAT THEIR MENTIONED THE
FIRST IS THE DISASTER RESPONSE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS ACCOUNT
-- THIS IS THE ACCOUNT THAT
THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE CAN
TRANSFER MONEY FROM THE ASSET
TO YOU THE SPECIAL FUND FOR
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES IN
AN EMERGENCY THAT ALREADY
LAPSED ON JANUARY FIRST AND OF
COURSE THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
WHENEVER THE NEXT EMERGENCY
COMES FOR THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT MONEY
INTO THAT ACCOUNT AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE SO THAT WHETHER
IT'S DEBRIS REMOVAL OR SOME
OTHER POST EMERGENCY SITUATION
THE GOVERNMENT CAN ADDRESS
IT QUICKLY -- AND SO WE'VE
REACHED A DEAL -- WORKING WITH
WHAT LEGISLATIVE STAFF WHERE
WE STAND THAT ALREADY WHILE
PRESERVING AND PROTECTING
THE LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY TO
APPROPRIATE AND OVERSEE THAT
MONEY -- AND THEN THE SECOND
PROVISION OF AB SEVENTY THREE
IS AN AMENDMENT OF SB OUTLET
NINETY FOUR FROM LAST YEAR
THIS IS A PRIVACY BILL ON
AND MAKE SURE TO KEEP THOSE
PRIVACY PROVISIONS WHILE
MAINTAINING -- INVESTIGATIONS
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH CIVIL
RIGHTS AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION SERVICES AS WELL AS
INVESTIGATIONS FROM THE P.
YOU SEE I AM TOO INNKEEPERS IN
COMMON CARRIERS ARE PASSENGER
MANIFESTS COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
OKAY SINGLE QUESTIONS ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY THREE
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION
TO AB SEVENTY THREE
OKAY SINGLE FURTHER COMMENT CAN
I GET A MOTION TO DO PASS AS
AMENDED FOR SECOND I THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY COULD YOU CALL
TING AYE TING AYE OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
AYE BLOOM BLOOM MIND BRO CHIU
COOPER COOPER AYE FONG FONG AYE
FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA GARCIA
I JONES SAWYER LACKEY LACKEY
AYE LIMÓN MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE MULLIN MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI AYE NAZARIAN AND
I O'DONNELL O'DONNELL AYE
PATTERSON PATTERSON I RAMOS
PROMISE AYE RADIUS RADIUS I
REVERSE REVERSE AYE RUBIO RUBIO
AYE STONE WEBER WICKS WICKS
I WOULD WHAT I I TWENTY FOUR
KNOW ZERO THANK YOU WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO THE OVERVIEW OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
CANASTA CAROLINE CHIU FROM THE
ALLELES OFFICE TO COME ON UP
A BIT -- MISTER THESE WHEN THE
THING IF YOU COULD CONTINUE
THE CORRECT YES AND THIS IS
A BIG BUDGETS ALL KEEP THIS
VERY VERY SHORT AND THEN ANY
QUESTIONS VERY HAPPY TO ANSWER
SO THIS IS A BUDGET A SPENDING
PLAN OF A HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL
FUND MONEY AND WHEN YOU INCLUDE
SPECIAL FUNDS AND OTHER BOND
FINDS THIS IS TWO HUNDRED NINE
BILLION DOLLARS OF SPENDING IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
AND THEY'RE BASICALLY -- THREE
POINTS THAT I WANT TO MAKE
ABOUT THIS BUDGET THE FIRST IS
THAT THIS IS A BUDGET THAT IS
REALLY BUILT ON A FOUNDATION
OUT BUDGET RESILIENCY AND WE
KNOW THIS IS A POINT THAT THE
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IN PUTTING OUT AT
THAT THEIR BUDGET BLUEPRINT --
ALSO MADE THIS POINT THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE NEW INVESTMENTS
NOW BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO MAKE
SURE TO SAVE FOR A RAINY DAY
IN AN ENVIRONMENT OF GROWING
RISKS SO THIS IS A BUDGET THAT
COMMITS FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
THAT PAYING OFF DEBTS IN
DEFERRALS THAT COMMITS NEARLY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO PAYING
OFF CALPERS CAL STIRS IN OTHER
RETIREMENT LIABILITY DEBT AND
THEN COMMITS MORE THAN FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS TO BUILDING
RESERVES AND THAT INCLUDES
IN A RAINY DAY FUND IN OUR
SPECIAL FUND FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES AND IN THE SAFETY
NET RESERVES AND MOST IMPORTANT
OF ALL FOR THIS SURPLUS THAT
WE EX PROJECTED THE CURRENT --
IN THE BUDGET YEAR OF TWENTY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS -- MORE
THAN EIGHTY PERCENT OF THAT IS
COMMITTED TO ONE TIME SPENDING
SO FOR EVERY DOLLAR THAT WE CAN
THAT IN AN ON GOING BASIS WE'RE
COMMITTING ABOUT SIX DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME SPENDING AND THAT
PROTECTS THE BUDGET IN FUTURE
YEARS THIS IS A BUDGET THAT'S
BALANCED OVER THE FORECAST
PERIOD NOT JUST THE BUDGET YEAR
BUT THE THREE YEARS FOLLOWING
THAT THE SECOND POINT I WANT
TO MAKE ABOUT THIS BUDGET IS
-- WE IT REALLY REFLECTS THE
GOVERNOR'S THEME OF CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL AND MAKING SURE THAT
EVERY PERSON HAS A SHOT AT THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM AND IT DOES SO
IN A NUMBER OF AREAS THE FIRST
IS AN EDUCATION WHERE FROM
CRADLE TO CAREER EVERYTHING
FROM HOME VISITING TO
SCREENINGS TO CHILDCARE PRE K.
ACCESS TO FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
THE HIGHEST EVER WEBER HIGHEST
EVER LEVEL OF INVESTMENT K.
TWELVE UNDER PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT AND LARGE ON GOING
INCREASES AND YOU SEE CSU A
SECOND YEAR OF FREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOR A FULL TIME FOR
YOUR STUDENTS -- WE THINK
THE EDUCATION PART OF THIS
BUDGET -- CAN MAKE A VERY BIG
DIFFERENCE FOR PEOPLE AND THAT
ALSO INCLUDES -- INCREASES AND
CAL WORKS PAID FAMILY LEAVE
AND THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT THAT CAN REALLY SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S HARD WORKING
FAMILIES NOT THE SECOND POINT
I WANT TO MAKE ABOUT THE NEW
INVESTMENTS IS IN HEALTH CARE
THIS BUDGET EXTENDS MEDI CAL
TO UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
UP TO AGE TWENTY SIX ON
THERE'S A BIG NEW INITIATIVE
ON PHARMACEUTICALS AND HOW WE
CAN REDUCE THE COST OF THOSE
DRUGS -- BIG INVESTMENTS IN
MENTAL HEALTH BOTH PROVIDERS
AND ACCESS TO CARE WE ALSO
ELIMINATE THE AS A SIDE CASH
OUT POLICY WHICH MAKES SURE
THAT PEOPLE CAN BE ELIGIBLE FOR
A SOCIETY WITHOUT LOSING ACCESS
TO COW FRESHEN OTHER BENEFITS
UNDER THAT PROGRAM ALSO WITHIN
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WE'RE COMMITTING TO ON GOING
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
IMMIGRATION FUNDING IN ADDITION
TO THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FIVE MILLION OF WHICH
YOU JUST VOTED ON -- JUST THIS
MINUTE THE THIRD POINT I WANT
TO MAKE ABOUT THIS BUDGET WHEN
IT COMES TO NEW INVESTMENTS
IS AN HOUSING HOMELESSNESS A
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN HOMELESSNESS OVER
A BILLION DOLLARS IN HOUSING
HAPPY TO GO INTO DETAIL BUT WE
THINK THESE WILL REALLY START
TO CHANGE THE GAME THE FOURTH
IS AN EMERGENCY RESPONSE IN
ADDITION TO SOME OF THE EARLY
ACTIONS THAT WE JUST DISCUSSED
THIS INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS UNDER THE NINE
A ONE LEGISLATION LAST YEAR FOR
FUEL REDUCTION NEW MONEY FOR
AIRCRAFT TO COMBAT WILDFIRES
FOR TECHNOLOGY AND OTHER
IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR EMERGENCY
SYSTEMS AND ALSO INCLUDE SOME
MONEY FOR THE WELLNESS OF OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS WOMEN OUT
THERE ON THE FRONT LINES FOR
DAYS EVEN WEEKS AT A TIME AND
THE LAST POINT I WANT TO MAKE
ABOUT THIS BUDGET IS THAT IT
INCLUDES A LOT ON ENVIRONMENTAL
GOALS INCLUDING OUR ONE BILLION
DOLLAR PROGRAM FOR CAP AND
TRADE MONEY -- WITH A FOCUS
AS WELL IN TERMS OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDING ON HEALTHY SOILS AS
WELL AS APPRENTICESHIPS FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRANSITIONING
INTO A LOW CARBON ECONOMY AND
FINALLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
STATE ITSELF TO THINGS THAT I
THINK THEIR MANSION IS NUMBER
ONE A WERE PROPOSING A NEW
OFFICE OFFICIAL INNOVATION
TECH TRANSFORM DIFFERENT
OFFICE OF STATE GOVERNMENT AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE MORE
RESPONSIVE TO THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY SERVED ME NOW THAT THIS
IS A PRIORITY FOR ALL OF US
NO MATTER WHAT PARTY AND THE
SECOND THING I'LL MENTION IS
AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CENSUS OUT REACH
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS
COMING OUT BECAUSE THAT IS
SO IMPORTANT TO GET EVERY
PERSON COUNTED TO HAVE A
REPRESENTATION IN CONGRESS AND
MAKING SURE THAT OUR PROGRAMS
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE
ALLOCATED BASED ON POPULATION
OR REFLECTING AN ACCURATE
ACCOUNT AND WITH ALL THIS ALL
SAY THAT YOU KNOW IT'S STILL
JANUARY ITS STATE TWENTY TWO
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION WE WILL
BE CLOSELY MONITORING REVENUES
IN THE FISCAL PICTURE WHEN WE
ALL GET TOGETHER AGAIN IN APRIL
AND NINE SO THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE HAVE MISSED CHIU REPRESENT
ALEJO'S OFFICE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
-- THE SERGEANTS I BELIEVE --
HANDED OUT OUR HAND OUT WHICH
I'LL JUST BE SPEAKING FROM TO
GIVE SOME HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
JOURNEY TO THE FIRST PAGE WE DO
OUR OWN HIGH LEVEL ASSESSMENT
OF THE BREAKDOWN OF WHAT WAS
AVAILABLE IN DISCRETIONARY
RESOURCES AT THE GOVERNOR FOR
HIS -- JANUARY BUDGET AFTER
ACCOUNTING FOR CONSTITUTIONAL
SPENDING REQUIREMENTS CASELOAD
CHANGES CHANGES I'M PROGRAM
COSTS A NEW LEGISLATION AND
WE ESTIMATE THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAD ABOUT TWENTY POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE
TO ALLOCATE THE FIGURE ON
THIS PAGE SHOWS YOU ON OUR
ASSESSMENT OF HOW THAT MONEY
WAS DISTRIBUTED AS YOU CAN
SEE ABOUT HALF WAS ALLOCATED
TO PAYING DOWN DEBTS AND
LIABILITIES A QUARTER TO NEW
ONE TIME PROGRAMMATIC SPENDING
AND THEN THE REMAINDER WAS
SPLIT ABOUT FIFTY FIFTY BETWEEN
DISCRETIONARY RESERVES AND
ON GOT NEW ON GOING SPENDING
TURNING TO THE NEXT PAGE THIS
TABLE PROVIDES A HIGH LEVEL
SUMMARY OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS NEW PROPOSALS FOR
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
SPENDING AS AS AS WAS ALREADY
MENTIONED THE LARGEST PROPOSAL
WITHIN PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
IS TO PROVIDE THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA A ROUGHLY THREE
POINT FIVE PERCENT COLA TO
INCREASE THE PER PEOPLE RATES
I'LL JUST OFFER SOME HIGH LEVEL
COMMENTS ON A FEW OF THE ITEMS
ON THIS TABLE STARTING WITH
DEBT LIABILITIES THE GOVERNOR
-- PROPOSES A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF DISCRETIONARY
RESOURCES TO GO TO PAINT ON
THESE THAT LIABILITY IS A LARGE
PROPORTION OF THESE WOULD GO
TOWARDS PENSION PAYMENTS THERE
IS ONE TRADE OFF TO HIGHLIGHT
HERE SPECIFICALLY THE GOVERNOR
ON PROPOSES TO PROVIDE ABOUT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS TO CAL
STIRS -- FROM STATE RESOURCES
A BUT TO PAY DOWN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT SHARE OF LIABILITIES
AS THE LEGISLATURE WILL RECALL
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THERE WAS A
FUNDING PLAN ADOPTED TO ADDRESS
THE END OF UNFUNDED LIABILITY
AND CAL STIRS AND DIVIDED THAT
LIABILITY BETWEEN THE STATE
AND SCHOOLS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL DEVIATE SOMEWHAT FROM
THAT PLAN BY PAYING A PORTION
OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT SHARE
-- FROM STATE RESOURCES THERE
ALSO ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER
PROPOSALS WITHIN THE GOVERNOR
SAID LIABILITY -- PACKAGE IN
THE COMING WEEKS WILL BE --
ISSUING REPORTS LOOKING AT
THESE PROPOSALS AND TRYING
TO EVALUATE -- WHICH ONES GET
-- THE STATE THE BEST BANG
FOR ITS BUCK IN THE BEST LONG
TERM SAVINGS AND EXAMINING
WHETHER THEIR ALTERNATIVES
THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY STATE
SAVE THE STATE MORE MONEY
ON RESERVES THIS NUMBER
ACTUALLY WITH A TWO POINT
NINE BILLION TO ALMOST THREE
BILLION DOLLARS ARE THIS IS
THE DISCRETIONARY AMOUNT OF --
RESERVES UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THIS NUMBER IS LIKELY
A BIT LOWER ONCE ACCOUNTING
FOR SOME ADDITIONAL SETTLE UP
PAYMENTS THAT ARE PROPOSED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT NOT
REFLECTED IN THE DOCUMENTS
MOVING TO EARLY EDUCATION --
I THINK -- MISTER VISWANATHAN
ALREADY MENTIONED -- THE
EXPANSION OF OF PRESCHOOL TO
ALL LOW INCOME STUDENTS IN
THE STATE OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD WE FIND THIS TO BE A
REASONABLE APPROACH AS THESE
CHILDREN -- THE RESEARCHERS
FOUND THAT THESE CHILDREN
BENEFIT THE MOST IN THE LONG
TERM FROM THESE TYPES OF OF
PROGRAMS ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES STARTING WITH CAL
WORKS THE -- ADMINISTRATION'S
APPROACH TO CAL WORKS IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT THE IMMINENT AND AND THEN
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
LAST YEAR SPECIFICALLY THE
ADMINISTRATION SIMPLY PROVIDES
AN ACROSS THE BOARD GRANT
INCREASE THE CONSEQUENCES
THAT NOT ALL FAMILY SIZES
WOULD NECESSARILY BE AT FIFTY
PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL WHICH IS THE TARGET THE
LEGISLATURE HAD SET LAST YEAR
ALSO WITHIN HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES ARM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- MAINTAINS THE SEVEN
PERCENT SERVICE REDUCTION
OF RESTORATION -- THAT WAS
COUPLED WITH THE MCO TAX BUT
THE ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT
CONTINUE THE MCO TAX AS PART
OF ITS BUDGET PACKAGE LASTLY
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
-- THE GOT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO INSTITUTE AN
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PENALTY
AND CUP AND COUPLE THAT WITH
ADDITIONAL SUBSIDIES ON THE
HEALTH CARE EXCHANGE WORKS A
LITTLE BIT OF CROSS PURPOSES
IN PARTICULAR IF THE PENALTY
IS DESIGNED CORRECTLY REVENUE
SHOULD DECLINE OVER TIME AS
INDIVIDUALS MAINTAIN OR GAIN
COVERAGE THIS COULD CREATE
SOME VOLATILITY IN THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR
SUBSIDIES FOR FOLKS PURCHASING
INSURANCE ON THE MARKET
OVER TIME SO THE LEGISLATURE
WILL JUST WANT TO CONSIDER
HOW TO ME KEEP THAT LEVEL
OF FUNDING STABLE OVER TIME
THE LAST POINT I'LL JUST REYES
IS ON THE REVENUE PROPOSAL
SPECIFIC SPECIFICALLY THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT AND
CONFORMITY POSITION UP PROP
UP EXCUSE ME PROPOSALS THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO COUPLE
THESE -- TOGETHER TO REACH A
REVENUE REVENUE NEUTRAL PACKAGE
ACHIEVING THIS LIKELY WOULD BE
VERY DIFFICULT -- AT DEVELOPING
EIGHT CONFORMITY PACKAGE BASED
ON THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN FEDERAL
CHANGES TO TAXES TO REACH
A PARTICULAR REVENUE TARGET
WOULD BE VERY CHALLENGING AND
WE RECOMMEND SPLITTING THESE
PROPOSALS AND CONSIDERING
THEM SEPARATELY THEY BOTH
HAVE MERIT BUT WE BELIEVE THEY
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED SEPARATELY
TURNING TO THE LAST PAGE I'LL
JUST PROVIDE SOME HIGH LEVEL
COMMENTS ON THE STRUCTURE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FIRST THE
GOVERNOR IDENTIFIES A NUMBER
OF POLICY PRIORITIES EARLY
MANY OF THESE ARE OUTLINES
OF OBJECTIVES OF THE GOVERNOR
WOULD LIKE TO REACH THE
ADVANTAGE FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF TIME FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO PUT ITS MARK
ON THESE POLICIES AND FORM AND
FORM THEM IN A WAY THAT ALIGNS
WITH ITS PRIORITIES MANY OF
THE PRIORITIES THE GOVERNOR
HAS HAS -- BROUGHT UP IN HIS
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALIGNED WITH
REACHED WITH RECENT LEGISLATIVE
ACTION THE SECOND COMMENT
ALL MAKE ON ON THE BUDGET
STRUCTURE IS ABOUT THE ONGOING
COSTS THE ONGOING COSTS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ABOUT TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR GOING TO THREE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS THE
YEAR AFTER THAT SOME OF THESE
COSTS COULD GROW HOWEVER FOR
INSTANCE DISASTER COSTS WHICH
ARE LARGELY -- CONSIDER ONE
TIME IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
HAVE IN RECENT YEARS PROVED
TO BE MORE OF AN ONGOING COSTS
SO THIS COULD INCREASE THE
OVERALL ONGOING COST IN THE
BUDGET -- AND MOREOVER -- THERE
ARE GOING RESOURCES AVAILABLE
MAYBE SOMEWHAT CHANGING AND ALL
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE AND REVENUES
AT THE END OF MY COMMENTS
ON THE BUDGET STRUCTURE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO --
DEDICATES A SMALLER PROPORTION
OF DISCRETIONARY RESOURCES
TOWARDS RESERVES COMPARED TO
RECENT BUDGETS PART OF THAT
IS DUE TO A NEW INTERPRETATION
OF PROPOSITION TWO THAT
NECESSITATES A ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLAR DEPOSIT INTO
THE BUDGET SUB STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT BUT THE OTHER ISSUE
THAT THIS BRINGS UP IS WHAT
ARE THE RESERVES BEING DESIGNED
FOR SO UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THERE'S ABOUT EIGHTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS OF RESERVES
ESTIMATED TO BE AVAILABLE AT
THE END OF NINETEEN TWENTY OUR
OFFICE HISTORICALLY CONSIDERS
THE SOME OUT TO BE THE AMOUNT
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE IN AN
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN TO COVER THE
COSTS OF ONGOING -- PROGRAMS
BUT IN RECENT YEARS WE'VE ALSO
SEEN THAT THESE RESOURCES WILL
WILL ALSO BE CALLED UPON TO
RESPOND TO DISASTERS SO ONE
OF POINT WE WOULD -- UP DIRECT
THE LEGISLATURE CHOOSE TO
THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH RESERVES
WOULD BE NECESSARY TO BOTH
ADDRESS AND ECONOMIC DOWNTURN
IN THE COSTS RELATED WITH
A DISASTER SIMULTANEOUSLY
WELL THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES
NOT DEDICATE AS MANY RESOURCES
TO DISCRETIONARY RESERVES IT
DOES AS I MENTIONED ALLOCATE
A SIGNIFICANT PROPORTION
OF RESOURCES TO PAYING DOWN
DEBT LIABILITIES WHICH DOES
IN THE LONG TERM REDUCE
-- -- THE ONGOING COSTS OF
THE BUDGET AND PUTS THE THE
BUDGET IN A BETTER CONDITION
WELL THE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT HAS A SIGNIFICANT
BALLOTS TO ADDRESS -- THE
NON SCHOOL SIDE OF THE BUDGET
THERE IS NO RESERVE AT THE
STATE LEVEL CURRENTLY FOR
SCHOOLS PROPOSITION TWO DID
CREATE A STATE LEVEL RESERVE
FOR SCHOOLS BUT THE FORMULAS
HAVE NOT YET REQUIRED THERE
TO BE A DEPOSIT INTO THAT
ACCOUNT SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
SAVING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT
IT IS STATE LEVEL THERE IS
NOT ANY DEDICATED RESERVES
FOR THEM IF THE LEGISLATURE
ANTICIPATED WANTING TO USE
FUNDING WITHIN ITS OTHER
WITH A RESERVE ACCOUNTS FOR
SCHOOLS IN THE EVENT OF A
DOWNTURN THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER HAVING
A HIGHER OVERALL LEVEL OF
RESERVES MOREOVER WITHIN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY GUARANTEED
THERE'S VERY LITTLE ONE TIME
SPENDING IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THE CONSEQUENCE OF THAT
IS THAT THERE IF IS IF THERE
IS A YEAR TO YEAR DECREASE
IN THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEED THERE COULD
BE IMPACTS TO THE ONGOING
PROGRAMS FOR SCHOOLS MY LAST
COMMENT WILL JUST WILL BE
ABOUT THE REVENUE ESTIMATES THE
GOVERNOR'S REVENUE ESTIMATES
ARE VERY CLOSE TO OURS VERY
VERY CLOSE TO OURS AND THAT
SAID BOTH OF OUR REVENUE
ESTIMATES WERE PUT TOGETHER
BEFORE THE DOWNTURN IN THE
MARKET AT THE END OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SO THERE IS REST
RELATED TO THE FINANCIAL MARKET
WE ALSO ARE SEEING WEAKNESS
IN THE FOURTH QUARTER PAYMENTS
WHICH ARE PAYMENTS BY HIGH
INCOME EARNERS ON THAT CAME IN
THIS JANUARY WE HAVE A COUPLE
MORE DAYS BUT WE'VE REALLY
SPROUT THE TAIL -- UNDER OUR
REVENUE ESTIMATES THIS AFFECT
OF THE LOWER MARKET -- AND THE
WEEK OF JANUARY WOULD LIKELY
ONLY REALLY BRING DOWN THE
ONE TIME AVAILABLE RESOURCES
IN THE BUDGET THIS IS BECAUSE
UNDER OUR REVENUE ESTIMATES
WE ASSUMED VÀ SLOW GROWTH IN
THE STOCK MARKET CONSEQUENTLY
THERE ISN'T A LARGE ON GOING
AFFECT OF THIS LOWER LEVEL ON
THE MARKET THERE IS SOME AFFECT
A FEW HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR BUT NOT IT'S NOT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS THE
THE SIZE OF THE WHAT WE'RE
STATES CURRENTLY SEEING IN THE
SHORTFALL IN THE REVENUES IF
YOU THINK UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
FRAMEWORK -- THE ONGOING
AVAILABLE RESOURCES ACTUALLY
ARE A LITTLE BIT HIGHER BECAUSE
THEY HAD LOWER PROGRAMMATIC
SPENDING THAN WE DID DUE TO
BIRTH REDUCTIONS IN THEIR
MEDI CAL COSTS SO WHEN YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT WHAT MIGHT BE
REASONABLE FOR ONGOING SPENDING
IN THE BUDGET YEAR THERE ARE
REVENUE ESTIMATES IT'S LIKELY
SOMEWHERE BELOW THREE BILLION
DOLLARS AND OUR PROGRAMMATIC
SPENDING ASSUMPTIONS UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S ESTIMATES THREE
BILLION DOLLARS LIKELY STILL IS
REASONABLE USING ALL OF THEIR
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT PROGRAMMATIC
COSTS THAT SAID THIS IS
ALL HIGHLY ON CERTAIN THE
ECONOMY AND THE MARKETS COULD
CHANGE OVER TIME AND WE'LL
WE'LL KNOW A LOT MORE IN MAY
SIX TWO COULD YOU JUST CLARIFY
AT THIS POINT WHAT IS THE
FOURTH QUARTER SHORTFALL THAT
YOU'RE SAYING IT'S IT'S IT'S
ABOUT -- TWO BILLION TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS WE DON'T
YET HAVE THE FINAL NUMBERS FOR
RE FUNDS THAT ARE BEING CLAIMED
AT THE END OF THIS MONTH BUT
IN THE PERSONAL INCOME TAX IT'S
IT'S HOVERING AROUND TWO POINT
FOUR TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS GREAT THANK YOU A TO
JUST TO PROVIDE SOME OVERALL
COMMON OVER THE BUDGET LAST
DECEMBER OUR OFFICE RELEASED
OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET BLUEPRINT
WERE VERY EXCITED TO SEE
MANY OF THE ELEMENTS THAT WE
DISCUSSED ALIGNED WITH WHAT THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED IN JANUARY
-- IN PARTICULAR OBVIOUSLY THE
EMPHASIS ON LARGE RESERVES --
THE LA -- RELEASED A REPORT
IN NOVEMBER TALKING ABOUT
THE NEED FOR POTENTIALLY EVEN
TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
OF RESERVES DURING A POTENTIAL
RECESSION SO WE'RE GLAD TO SEE
THAT THE GOVERNOR CONTINUE TO
PROPOSE A SIGNIFICANT RESERVES
ALSO -- PAYING DOWN DEBTS
LIABILITIES HAVING DONE IT
THIS IS REGARDING THE PENSION
LIABILITIES WE THOUGHT WAS
VERY RESPONSIBLE AND AND MADE
A LOT OF SENSE THE HEAVY FOCUS
ON ONE TIME INVESTMENT WEATHER
WAS HOUSING HOMELESSNESS EARLY
EDUCATION AT THE KINDERGARTEN
CLASSROOMS DOES SEEM TO BE
AGAIN -- IN LINE WITH OUR
OUR THINKING ESPECIALLY WITH
POTENTIAL RECESSION LOOMING
-- WE ALSO AGAIN WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT MANY OF THE
NEW INVESTMENTS THE CONTINUED
INVESTMENTS THAT WE MAY THAT WE
HAD MADE IN THE PAST BUILDING
ON THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
BY CONTINUING THE INCREASING
CAO WORKS GRANTS MANY OF
THOSE FAMILIES HAD NOT SEEN
-- REALLY INCREASES IN OVER
A DECADE OBVIOUSLY -- I THE
ISSUE THAT WE HAD CHAMPIONED
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET BUT
WERE ULTIMATELY NOT SUCCESSFUL
WAS REALLY AROUND INCREASING
HEALTH CARE ACCESS TO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE -- INCREASE IN
MEDI CAL ESPECIALLY FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE GOING FROM EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND BEING THAT
WAS A VERY PROMINENT IN OUR
ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL AT THE END
OF LAST YEAR THAT AND LASTLY --
OUR EARLY EDUCATION HAS ALWAYS
BEEN A HUGE PRIORITY FOR FOR
THIS BODY WE'RE REALLY GLAD TO
SEE THE GOVERNOR VERY MUCH HERE
THAT AND HE ALSO INCORPORATE
MUCH OF OUR THINKING IN THE
EARLY EDUCATION PROPOSAL ON
HAVING SAID THAT I KNOW THAT
WE'RE ALL CONCERNED THAT
WITH THE RECESSION LOOMING
HOW THIS REALLY IMPACTS ARE
FEELING ABOUT ONE TIME VERSUS
ONGOING SPENDING -- WE THINK
THAT THIS PROPOSAL AT THIS
POINT IS FOR A RESPONSIBLE
BUT OBVIOUSLY GIVEN MISSED HIS
COMMENTS ABOUT THE THE REVENUE
ESTIMATES IN THE CONTINUING
SHORTFALL IN REVENUE ESTIMATES
WERE OBVIOUSLY ARE GOING TO BE
WATCHING THAT VERY CLOSELY ON
IN MOST YOU KNOW JUST OF THE
FINAL POINT IS WE WOULD LIKE TO
SAY IS THAT WERE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL BECAUSE
IN YEARS PAST -- THE JANUARY
PROPOSALS WERE FRANKLY FAIRLY
THIN AND -- DIDN'T HAVE AS
MUCH OGDEN ALLOW REALLY AS MUCH
-- ROBUST DISCUSSION FROM THE
FEBRUARY TO MAY PERIOD GIVEN
THAT MANY OF THE LARGER POLLS
ARE RELEASED NOW IN JANUARY
WE'RE EXCITED THAT EACH OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEES WILL HAVE A
CHANCE TO REALLY FEDERAL DONE
ON MANY OF THESE VERY LARGE
VERY SIGNIFICANT POLICY ALSO
WITHOUT GOING TO TURN OVER TO
MR OBERNOLTE FOR ANY COMMENTS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAD A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS I'M GONNA
START WITH THE LA -- -- YOU'D
MENTIONED IN YOUR TESTIMONY
THAT THE CHARACTERIZATION OF
THE PRE FUNDING TOWARDS THE
CAL STIRS UNFUNDED LIABILITY
WAS DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO PUT
TOWARDS CALPERS UNFUNDED
LIABILITY SO IT'S THREE THREE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR CALPERS
UNFUNDED LIABILITY A DIRECT
PAYMENT TO PAY DOWN THAT
LIABILITY BUT IN CAL STIRS IT'S
WORDED IN A WAY THAT ENABLES
THE DISTRICTS TO REDUCE THEIR
CONTRIBUTION RATES SO I WANNA
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND -- THAT
TWO POINT THREE BILLION WILL
THAT RESULT IN A REDUCTION AND
CAL STIRS UNFUNDED LIABILITY
IF IT JUST IF THE DISTRICTS
JUST PAY LESS WITH THAT MONEY
OR -- THE RIGHT OR IS IT JUST
GOING TO BE A NET ZERO SO THE
SO THE THE GOVERNOR HAS TO CAL
STIRS PROPOSES THE TO PAY THE
AND WITHIN THE DISTRICT SIDE
OF THE LIABILITY THERE SORT
OF TWO TRACKS ON THE DISTRICTS
SIDE OF THE LIABILITY OF THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES PROVIDE TO
PROVIDE SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO CAL STIRS TO PAY
DOWN TO BASICALLY PAY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CONTRIBUTIONS FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR AND THE YEAR AFTER
THAT THE GOVERNOR ALSO PROPOSES
TO PROVIDE TWO POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS TO PAY DOWN
THE OVERALL UNFUNDED LIABILITY
ON THE SCHOOL DISTRICT SIDE OF
THE LEDGER OKAY I UNDERSTAND
SO WOULD YOU RECOMMEND THAT
THAT SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS BE -- PUT DIRECTLY
TOWARDS THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY
OR OR DO YOU THINK THAT THAT
IT'S FISCALLY PRUDENT WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
THERE ARE THERE ARE TRADE OFFS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL -- IN TERMS OF THE
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
GIVING DISTRICTS RATE RELIEF
AT A TIME -- CAL STIRS RATE
RELIEF AT A TIME WHEN THEIR
OVERALL FUNDING IS RELATIVELY
HIGH MEANS THAT THAT THAT
FUNDING MIGHT NOT BE AVAILABLE
IN A YEAR -- WHEN THEY'RE WHEN
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT IS
DECLINING YEAR OVER YEAR AND
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER HOLDING THAT MONEY
IN RESERVE TO PROVIDE THAT
KIND OF RELIEF TO DISTRICTS
IN A YEAR OP WHEN REVENUE IS
DECLINING THANK YOU I'M FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET
NOTICES INTENT TO RAISE TAXES
ON A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT
AREAS THERE'S A PROPOSED TAX
ON TELEPHONE SERVICE TO FUND
THE NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM AND
THERE IS A PROPOSED TAX ON
DRINKING WATER AND FERTILIZER
AND SOME OTHER THINGS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS CONSIDERED IN
PREVIOUS YEARS TO FUND -- CLEAN
DRINKING WATER IN COMMUNITIES
THAT DON'T YET HAVE IT AND
I THINK WE ARE ALL UNITED
IN OUR BELIEF THAT THOSE ARE
WORTHWHILE CAUSES BUT -- I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT WHY FIRST OF
ALL WE'RE NOT JUST FUNDING
THOSE THINGS OUT OF THE GENERAL
FUND GIVEN THAT THEY SEEM TO BE
ONE TIME CAPITAL EXPENDITURES
AND NOT ONGOING EXPENSES AND
SECOND OF ALL I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PERCEPTION OF US
RAISING TAXES ON CALIFORNIANS
IN A YEAR WHEN THE STATE HAS
A TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
SURPLUS JOE COULD YOU ADDRESS
WHY WE'RE TAKING THAT APPROACH
SURE SO FIRST THING I'LL SAY IS
THAT IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
-- GOVERNOR PROPOSES RAISING
AN ONGOING SOURCE OF REVENUE
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES BUT THE
ACTUAL DETAILS OF THAT WE KNOW
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO WORK
OUT WITH THE LEGISLATURE OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE MONTHS I THINK
THE SECOND THING AS THE LA --
MENTIONED BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS
BIG SURPLUS BUT SO LITTLE OF
IT IS ONE TIME AND THESE ARE
SUCH IMPORTANT PRIORITIES AND
MAKING SURE OUR DRINKING WATER
IS SAFE FOR MAKING SURE THAT
OUR EMERGENCY RESPONSE SYSTEM
IS ALWAYS UP TO DATE -- THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT THE GOVERNOR
BELIEVES CAN BE FIXED IN A
YEAR OR TWO OR EVEN THREE YEARS
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS AN ONGOING FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THAT -- SO WHEN IT
COMES TO THE ACTUAL ACTIONS
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DISCUSSED
EARLIER TODAY WE VIEWED AS
VERY MUCH EMERGENCY ACTIONS
THAT WE WANT TO TAKE RIGHT
NOW -- BUT GOING FORWARD WE
THOUGHT THAT IF THESE PROGRAMS
IN OUR BUDGET WERE A FUNCTION
OF THE GENERAL FUND AND IF THE
GENERAL FUND WERE TO DROP IN
A SIGNIFICANT WAY AND LA --
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS
BIKE'S UNDER THE RECESSION
SCENARIO THAT OUR DEPARTMENT
HAS MODELED REVENUES COULD
DROP BY TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN A SINGLE YEAR AND
NEARLY SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THREE YEARS SENSITIVE
CUTS ACROSS A RANGE OF PROGRAMS
-- AND THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
SEEN AS DISCRETIONARY SUCH AS
THESE PROGRAMS OFTEN WILL GET
THE AX WHEN AS YOU CAN JUST
MATCHING WE ALL AGREE THERE
ANYTHING BUT DISCRETIONARY
FROM A MORAL POINT OF VIEW SO
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS SOME TYPE OF DEDICATED
REVENUE SOURCE SO THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE INVOLVED BUT
WE DO UNDERSTAND THERE ARE
DIFFERENT VIEWS OF THIS --
AT BOTH OF THESE -- PROPOSED
REVENUE INCREASES AND WE LOOK
FOR TO SPEAKING WITH YOU OKAY
AYE AYE PROJECT THAT'S GOING
TO BE A DIFFICULT CONVERSATION
TO HAVE A NIGHT JUST SPEAKING
FOR MYSELF -- I THINK THAT --
I WOULD PREFER THAT WE SPEND
THAT MONEY OUT OF THE GENERAL
FUND WHEN WE HAVE WITH THE
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS SURPLUS
AND THEN HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE NEED FOR MORE ONGOING
FUNDING MAYBE IN YEARS WHEN
WE DON'T HAVE THAT SURPLUS AND
THAT JUST ONE FINAL QUESTION
FOR YOU IS THAT IT'S IN A YEAR
WHEN WE HAVE A SURPLUS WE GET
TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT
UNMET NEEDS WE GET TO ADDRESS
IN THE STATE AND ONE THING THAT
I THOUGHT WAS GLARINGLY ABSENT
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION'S
BUDGET WAS TO ADDRESS THE --
FOR SHORTFALL IN JUDGES IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IS YOU KNOW SAYS A WERE
A HUNDRED NINETY JUDGES SHORT
RIGHT NOW LAST YEAR THE BUDGET
PROPOSED TO NEW JUDGES AND THIS
YEAR THE ADMINISTRATIONS BUDGET
RIGHT NOW HAS NO NEW JUDGES
IN THERE AND -- I REPRESENT
SAN BENITO COUNTY WHICH IS
THE MOST UNDER RESOURCE PART
OF THE SUPPORT IN THE ENTIRE
STATE I WAS VERY DISAPPOINTING
TO TO ME TO SEE THAT I WONDER
WHY THAT DECISION WAS MADE SO
I WILL HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON THE SPECIFICS FOR A NUMBER
OF JUDGES BUT THE BUDGET DOES
INCLUDE INCREASES FOR COURTS
IN PUBLIC SAFETY GENERALLY
BUT ON THAT SPECIFIC ISSUE
ALL HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOUR
THINK IT'S MAKING MISTER MISS
MATHIS HAD A QUICK FOLLOW UP
ON THE WATER RUSHES LE LET HIM
THEN YOU MISTER CHAIR WITH WITH
THE WATER -- I'M GLAD TO SEE
THE GOVERNOR ACTUALLY COMMITTED
TO FINALLY DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT CLEAN DRINKING WATER -- I
DO HAVE SEVERAL CONCERNS ABOUT
THE PROPOSED TAX MEASURES THAT
HE'S TALKED ABOUT PUBLICLY --
JUST BEING THAT I COME FROM
ROLE COMMUNITY -- VIEW SIDE
PORTABLE WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
WORK -- ON CLEAN DRINKING WATER
SAID IN A PROGRAMS EVERYTHING
ELSE AND -- THE PROPOSED
NUMBERS I'VE SEEN AT LEAST IN
THE MEDIA FROM THE GOVERNOR --
ARE SERIOUSLY JUST A DROP IN
THE BUCKET FOR WHAT'S NEEDED
-- EXPRESSLY WITH ON GOING
AND KEEPING -- THESE PLANTS
RUNNING FOR THESE DISADVANTAGES
COMMUNITIES THAT WE HAVE I MEAN
I'VE BEEN TO SITES WHERE WE
HAVE BRAND NEW TREATMENT PLANTS
IN THE COMMUNITIES ARE JUST
TOO POOR TO BE ABLE TO PAY TO
KEEP THEM RUNNING AND WHAT HE'S
PROPOSING WITH THANK THE LAST
SUMMER SO I WAS TWENTY FIVE
MILLION -- TH THAT WOULD COME
FROM THIS NEW WATER TAX THAT'S
JUST NOT ENOUGH A AND I'VE GOT
AGREE WE NEED SOMETHING MORE
PERMANENT -- GENERAL FUND MONEY
GOING TOWARDS THIS THAT WE CAN
COUNT ON THAT'S GOING TO BE
ABLE TO PAY FOR NEW PROJECTS
AND ONGOING MAINTENANCE AND
I WOULD LOVE TO TALK WITH --
WHOEVER FROM YOUR OFFICE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON A PROPOSAL
THAT I HAVE THAT I THINK
WOULD BE MUCH BETTER SUITED
YES SO THAT -- FIRST POINT
IS THE GOVERNOR ABSOLUTELY
AGREES WITH YOU THAT TWENTY
OR TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IS NOT ENOUGH AND HE HAS BEEN
DEMONSTRATED A MORAL COMMITMENT
TO THESE ISSUES INCLUDING IN
THE CENTRAL ESPECIALLY THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN MAKING SURE
THAT PEOPLE EVERYWHERE IN THE
STATE HAVE ACCESS TO CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER SO THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
AND ACTUALLY TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF THAT IS WHAT WE --
THE COMMITTEE VOTED ON TODAY TO
MOVE OUT OF COMMITTEE THAT --
THE GOVERNOR AND HIS TEAM BUTTE
IS REALLY EMERGENCY SITUATIONS
FOR EMERGENCY AVAILABILITY AND
MAKING SURE THAT WATER SYSTEMS
CAN STEP UP AND BEGIN TO COMPLY
WITH A CLEAN DRINKING WATER
STANDARDS BUT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT SOLVING THIS ISSUE IN ANY
SORT OF SIGMUND WIDE WILL TAKE
MUCH MORE RESOURCES THAN THAT
HOW WE GET THE REVENUE TO DO
THAT AND WHERE WE SPEND FROM AS
WE WERE DISCUSSING THE SOMEONE
NUMBER OBERNOLTE THAT WILL
BE A LONGER CONVERSATION BUT
THAT'S CERTAINLY A COMMITMENT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION SHARES
WITH YOU THAT ABSOLUTELY --
WITH WITH AC THREE THAT WE'RE
PUTTING FORWARD -- WE'RE
LOOKING AT TWO PERCENT OF THE
GENERAL FUND AS A POSSIBLE
ANSWER WHICH WOULD BE A LITTLE
OVER FOUR BILLION ANNUALLY TO
THAT WOULD COVER NEW PROJECTS
PLUS THE MAINTENANCE FOR THEM
SO LIKE I SAID I'D LOVE TO
DISCUSS FARTHER OR FORTY TYPE
DISCUSSING THANK YOU THINK IT
WAS FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT -- OVERVIEW OF -- UPCOMING
BUDGET ONE OF THE THINGS IT
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME THAT
WE SEEM TO HISTORICALLY UNDER
VALUE IS THE NEED TO -- CATCH
UP WITH ID DE FUNDING TO DDS --
YOU KNOW OVER THE LAST DECADE
THE CENSUS IS GROWN TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF INDIVIDUALS UP TO
ALMOST A MILLION INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA AT HAVE INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
-- BUT ACTUALLY WHEN YOU LOOK
AT WHAT WE'VE DONE WITH THE
HAVE TO A BUILDING IN WHAT I
WOULD CALL THE FURLOUGHS WERE
ACTUALLY DECREASING SUCCESS
RATES FOR THE ID POPULATION OF
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IS YOU
HAVE TO LIFE SKILLS CLASSES
AT EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWO
IS VIRTUALLY NON WE HAVE NO
POSITIVE OUTCOME INVESTMENT
FOR THE ID POPULATION I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO SPEAKING
WITH SOMEBODY WHERE WE CAN
MAKE A TEMPLATE AND BUILD A
PLAN TO GO FORWARD WITH THE ID
IDT POPULATION -- AGAIN OVER
THE LAST DECADE JUST TARGETED
AUG AUGMENTATION WE'VE HAD
AND AND DISMISSED OR DISSOLVE
THE -- DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
IN CALIFORNIA TO SAVE MONEY
BUT YET THE INDIVIDUALS ARE
UNDER FUNDED AND WE HAVE
A NEED FOR SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX CASE WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA TO REGIONAL CENTERS
-- WE TALK ABOUT POSITIVE
OUTCOMES FOR EARLY EDUCATION
WE REALLY NEED TO WORK
ON POSITIVE OUTCOMES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO BE
JUST LIKE US AND SO I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HOW WE CAN HAVE A
GOAL TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
POPULATION IS RECOGNIZED AND
VALUES FOR SUCCESSFUL OUTCOMES
BUT I HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING
IN THE BUDGET THAT REALLY
TARGETS AT TÔI SO LET ME TAKE
MAKE TWO OR THREE QUICK POINTS
AND THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE TO RESET AS WELL
THE FIRST IS THAT THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE ARE TRACKING VERY
CLOSELY SO WE WANT TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH YOU AND ONE
OF THE REASONS WE HAD MAYBE
LESS DETAIL IN OUR JANUARY
PROPOSAL THEN WE HOPE TO HAVE
IN A COUPLE MONTHS BEFORE THE
BUDGET IS ENACTED IS AS YOU
KNOW THERE IS A RIGHT STUDY
THAT'S COMING OUT THIS SPRING
AND SO THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU
KNOW ONCE THAT COMES OUT WILL
HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF HOW WE
WANT TO MOVE IN WHAT DIRECTIONS
HOW MUCH IT'LL COST AND YOU THE
RATE STUDY DEALS WITH RATES BUT
THEN THERE'S ALSO THE QUESTION
OF HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE
CHANGE THE LAWS AND REGULATIONS
AROUND THAT SO THE SYSTEM IS
ACTUALLY WORKING FOR PEOPLE
AND ZOOMING OUT FROM THAT
EVEN AS WE HOPE TO COMMIT MORE
RESOURCES YOU KNOW WHICH WE
LIKELY WELL YOU KNOW ONE THAT
RATE STUDY COMES AND WE THINK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN HELP PEOPLE IN
THESE POPULATIONS WE ALSO HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY DOLLARS
ACTUALLY BEING WELL SPENT
AND I KNOW I'M SURE THAT'S A
PARTY THERE IS A SMALL MAKE
SURE IT'S GETTING TO THE RIGHT
PLACES AND PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
GETTING BETTER OUTCOMES AND
THE LAST POINT I'LL MAKE
BEFORE TURNING IT OVER TED
FREE SIZE AND OUR K.
TWELVE -- PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT BUDGET WE ALSO INCLUDE
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
MONEY FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND WE HOPE AND EXPECT THAT
MUCH OF THAT MONEY WILL GO
TOWARD KIDS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES WHO NEED OUR HELP
I APPRECIATE THAT AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT REALLY REALLY
I'M HOPING FOR IS WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE RATE STUDY DUE
MARCH FIRST -- I MEAN WE HAVE
INDIVIDUALS THROUGH PROVIDERS
THAT ARE SENDING OUT REST OF
WORKERS FOR MINIMUM WAGE AND
THEY DON'T THEY DON'T HAVE A
FULL TIME JOB THERE -- PART
TIME AT BEST -- THEY CAN MAKE
MORE MONEY TO LIVE IN PEACE
AND GETTING TIPS AND TAKING
CARE OF A MEDICALLY FRAGILE
BEHAVIORAL PROBLEM INDIVIDUAL
WITH AUTISM AND WE'RE NOT
RECOGNIZING THE VALUE OF WHAT
THIS HAPPENS WITH FAMILIES
WHEN YOU HAVE A MORTALITY
RATE OF EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT OF
MARRIAGES WITH CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES AND THIS DANGER
WE NEED TO CARE MORE WE NEED
TO BE INVESTING IN THIS PROCESS
TO TAKE CARE OF THESE CHILDREN
EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE -- I
CHAMPION FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT AND ALL THE OTHER
WITH A TYPICAL CHILD WE CAN'T
LEAVE THIS POPULATION BEHIND
ABSOLUTELY AND I CAN TELL YOU
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR THAT
HE IS A KINDRED SPIRIT WHEN
IT COMES TO THAT COMMITMENT
SOME TWEAKS SURE THERESA COLOR
A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST
TO ADD AS TO WHAT'S INCLUDED
IN THE JANUARY BUDGET STAR
EFFORTS AND RESOURCES PROPOSE
FOR -- ENHANCE CASELOAD
RATIOS ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE A
SPECIALIZED NEEDS SO GOING TO
YEAR -- CASE WORKER COMMENT
EARLIER THERE ARE RESOURCES
THERE IN THE JANUARY BUDGET
AS WELL AS RESOURCES FOR A NEW
-- COMMUNITY CRISIS HOME MODEL
TO ALSO SERVE THOSE CHILDREN
THE COMMUNITY THAT HAVE AGAIN
ENHANCE NEEDS AS PART OF THIS
POPULATION SO THERE'S A COUPLE
EXAMPLES OF THINGS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN JANUARY APPRECIATE
THEM IN WHAT I WOULD HOPE THAT
WE ALSO LOOK AT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TRAIN THESE INDIVIDUALS
PROPERLY THAT WE'RE NOT JUST
SENDING OUT AN INDIVIDUAL TO
TO JUST BE A BODY OR A BILLABLE
HOURS INDIVIDUALS FOR RESPITE
BEHAVIORAL AND ABA ALL OF
THESE THINGS THAT ARE GOING FOR
THE WE LOOK AT FUNDING PROPER
CREATING FOR THIS POPULATION SO
THAT THEY ARE THE POPULATIONS
CARED FOR THE MATTER WHICH
STATUS OR STUFF LIKE THAT THANK
YOU MISTER STONE I THINK I
JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP BRIEFLY
ON THE THE ISSUE ABOUT THE
WATER AT THE WAY I READ THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS IT'S
SOME NEAR TERM MONEY BUT ALSO
A WILLINGNESS TO LOOK LONG
TERM THE CHALLENGES WE'VE HAD
IN THE LAST ADMINISTRATION
IS PRETTY CLEAR ON THIS THAT
THERE HAS BEEN MONEY AVAILABLE
FOR CAPITAL COSTS AND FOR
SOME OF THE IMPROVEMENTS IN
WATER QUALITY BUT NOTHING WITH
RESPECT TO ONGOING OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE AND THAT SPEND
THE WEAKNESS SO FOR US TO
EXPECT THE GENERAL FUND AND
IT'S VOLATILITY ENDS ALL OF THE
VOTER DRIVEN LEGISLATIVE DRIVEN
CONSTRAINTS ON THE GENERAL
FUND TO BUILD ANYTHING LONG
TERM AND EXPECTED GENERAL FUND
TO MEET THAT THAT THAT NEED
I THINK IS IT APPROPRIATE AND
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND THE HISTORY
OF THE OF THE GENERAL FUND
SO I THAT I'M LOOKING FOR THE
DETAILS FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ABOUT HOW WE LOOK
PERMANENT FOR PERMANENT FUNDING
TO ADDRESS THE OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE PERSPECTIVE AND
THAT'S SORT OF HOW I READ THAT
PROPOSAL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
TO SEE HOW THAT DEVELOPS OVER
TIME I THINK THAT'S A VERY
HEALTHY PERSPECTIVE ON HOW
WE MEET THIS NEED A CRITICAL
NEED ACROSS CALIFORNIA IT'S
TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN AND
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO TURN ON THE
TAP AND CAN'T DRINK THE WATER
FROM THEIR TASK THAT SHOULD
BE AN EMBARRASSMENT TO ALL OF
US AND BUT WE WE HAVE TO BE
VERY CAREFUL HOW WE'RE FINDING
IT AND THAT WE ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE LONG TERM FUNDING FOR
THE OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
PIECES OF IT BECAUSE WILL
ALWAYS BE ABLE TO TO PULL UP
MONEY FOR CAPITAL COSTS AT ONE
TIME AND USE THAT AS WE DID
WHEN THAT'S GREAT NOW BUT IF
WE DON'T ADDRESS THE LONG TERM
AND IF WE T¡I EVERYTHING TO
THE GENERAL FUND THEN WE WILL
IN FACT SHORT CHANGE THOSE
COMMUNITIES OVER TIME WE CAN'T
KEEP DOING THAT AND SO AYE
DADDY MUST SAY I DO APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ON THIS AND PERSPECTIVE
ON THIS AND I KNOW WE WILL
BE WORKING ON IT OVER THE
YEARS SO THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
FUNG IN THEIR MISTER MISTER
MURATSUCHI -- A PUBLIC
UP AROUND FROM FROM --
FROM VARIOUS ISSUES BUT IN
TERMS OF EARLY EDUCATION
FUNDING HOW MUCH OF THE ONE
TIME FUNDING WILL GO TO EXPAND
CAPACITY -- WITH THERE'S
CERTAINLY A NEED TO TO FIND
-- EARLY EDUCATION SLOTS BUT A
LOT OF COMMUNITIES DON'T HAVE
CAPACITY TO -- TO ACTUALLY
PROVIDE EARLY EDUCATION SO YOU
CAN SPEND ON THAT YES -- SO
THERE AND TWO STREAMS OF IT
THE FIRST IS FOR KINDERGARTEN
CAPACITY AND AS YOU KNOW
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE UNIVERSAL
KINDERGARTEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA
NOT EVERYBODY HAS A FULL DAY
OPTION IN FACT ABOUT TWENTY
PERCENT IT'S I BELIEVE IT
DISTRICTS -- ONLY DON'T OFFER
A FULL DAY OPTION TO ALL
ELIGIBLE KINDERGARTENERS AND
A LOT OF THAT AS YOU MENTIONED
IS A CAPACITY ISSUE SO THIS
BUDGET PROPOSES IN ONE TIME
FINDING SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO RETROFIT
THESE CLASSROOMS -- BUILD NEW
CLASSROOMS AS NEEDED AND MAKING
SURE ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THESE
CLASSROOMS FOR KINDERGARTNERS
WITH BATHROOM SET UP IN THE
WAY THE TEACHERS ARE THEY
HAVE TO BE RETROFITTED IN A
CERTAIN WAY SO WE'RE HOPING
THAT THAT SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WILL GO A
LONG WAY THE OTHER EXTREME OF
ONE TIME FINDING THAT BEARS
MENTIONING IS FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND THIS IS FOR
CHILD CARE WHICH IS ALSO A BIG
PRIORITY OF THE ADMINISTRATION
EXPANDING ACCESS TO CHILDCARE
AND THIS IS BOTH FOR CHILD
CARE FACILITY CAPACITY AS
WELL AS TRAINING OF THE CHILD
CARE WORKFORCE BECAUSE WE
ALSO HAVE A WORK FORCE ISSUE
THERE -- IT'S IF WE WANT TO
IMPROVE CHILD CARE WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE IMPROVE THE
NUMBER OF CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
SAID THOSE TWO TOGETHER COME
TO ONE POINT TWO FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING
IS THERE A FORMULA IN TERMS
OF HOW THE RESOURCES WILL BE
-- ALLOCATED IS IT DOESN'T GO
BY POPULATION DOES IT GO BY
WAIT LIST AS A GO BY REGION
SO WE HAVEN'T PUT THAT IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET BUT I'LL LET MY
COLLEAGUE JESSICA HOLMES SPEAK
ABOUT THAT YES THANK YOU JUST
COMES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO
GENERALLY SPEAKING -- IN PAST
YEARS BECAUSE WE HAVE WE HAVE
-- IT PRIOR LEGISLATURE'S HAVE
FUNDED THIS TYPE OF ACTIVITY
BEFORE -- WE'VE GONE OUT ON
A -- RFA REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL
ARE FEW PROCESS SO PEOPLE
HAVE APPLIED FOR THE FUNDS AND
AND IN PRIOR YEARS WE'VE HAD
LANGUAGE AROUND PRIORITIZATION
FOR AREAS OF THE STATE THAT
HAVE RELATIVELY LOW ACCESS
CAPACITY AT THIS POINT -- JUST
IN RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
THE ACCESS IS AN ISSUE IT'S
NOT CONSISTENT ACROSS THE STATE
THANK YOU -- IN TERMS OF GOING
TO -- TO TRANSPORTATION CAN
YOU PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DETAILS
ON THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
LINK TRANSPORTATION FUNDS --
TO A REGION'S HOUSING -- NEEDS
SO WHEN IT COMES TO THE
GOVERNOR'S HOUSING PROPOSAL
THERE'S A SHORT TERM POCKET
AND A LONGER TERM POCKET FOR
THE SHORTER TERM BALK AT THAT
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE DOLLARS AND TECHNICAL
AND OTHER ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE WILLING
TO STEP UP AND THEN FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AS
THESE JURISDICTIONS MEET THEIR
MILESTONES SO THAT HOUSING
PROCESS IS NOT RELATED TO SB
WINE OR ANY OTHER I NEED THE
OTHER TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
THAT BEING SAID WHEN IT COMES
TO THE LONGER TERM ISSUE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED SAT
LOOKING AT THIS AND REACHING
THESE GOALS OVER THE LONG TERM
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE RENO
PROCESS FOR SETTING REGIONAL
HOUSING GOALS IN CONCERT WITH
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS NEEDS TO
BE REVAMPED AND THAT ONCE WE DO
THAT WE DO NEED TO HAVE A WAY
OF HOLDING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR MEETING
THEIR HOUSING GOALS BECAUSE
WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE GOVERNOR
HAS SUGGESTED THAT ONE WAY
OF HOLDING JURISDICTIONS
ACCOUNTABLE IS WITHHOLDING SOME
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING IF THEY
DO NOT MEET THOSE GOALS NOW
THE WAITED THAT WE ACTUALLY
DO THAT -- AS I MENTIONED THIS
IS A LONGER TERM PROPOSITION
SO IT'S NOT HAPPENING IN THIS
CURRENT YEAR IT'S NOT HAPPENING
IN THE BUDGET YEAR THE DETAILS
OF THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
WANT TO WORK OUT WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE WE WANT
THESE GOALS THEY WILL BE HARD
FOR SOME COMMUNITIES TO ACHIEVE
BUT WE DON'T WANT THEM TO BE
HOPELESS THEY'RE DESIGNED AS
PART OF THAT REVAMPS PROCESS
TO BE ACHIEVABLE AND I THINK
THE OTHER THING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SIGNALED
IS THAT IF DOWN THE ROAD A
COMMUNITY IS NOT MEETING ITS
HOUSING GOALS AND SOME OF
THAT SB ONE MONIES BUT HELD
ITS NOT COMPLETELY TAKEN
AWAY IT'S A JURISDICTIONS GET
BACK IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
HOUSING GOALS THAT WE'VE ALL
COMMITTED TO THEY WILL BE ABLE
TO ACCESS THAT MONEY SO WE
KNOW THERE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
AROUND THIS PROPOSAL IT'S A
LONGER TERM PROPOSITION AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON DESIGNING IT SO
THAT IT ACTUALLY CHIEF THE
GOALS FOR WHICH IT'S INTENDED
I DON'T KNOW IF IT DID
YOU HAVE ANYTHING ELSE AT
-- I THINK THE CONCERN THERE
IS THAT IS CERTAINLY THE THE
GOVERNOR HAS MENTIONED THAT
HOUSING TRANSMISSION ARE ARE
LINKED IT IN MANY INSTANCES AS
IF THEY CAN'T BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THEN YOU'RE FORCING
INDIVIDUALS TO MOVE FURTHER
AWAY AND SO I THINK FROM FROM
MANY INSTANCES I DON'T KNOW
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT'S FAIR TO
LINK TRANSPORTATION TO HOUSING
GOALS IF YOU THINK YOU SIX
TAKE A STEP BACK THERE'S OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES AT RK THE ART IN
THE CONTROL OF THE LEGISLATURE
SO WHAT I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES IS THAT
THAT THAT COULD THAT COULD BE
CRISES ARE RIGHT NOW HOUSING
CRISIS IS LYING TO YOU KNOW
LACK OF TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS
SO WE DEFINITELY DO AGREE THERE
THAT THESE TWO THINGS GO HAND
IN HAND BUT WE ALSO THINK THAT
THEY THEY CONVERGE TOGETHER
AND THEY WORK TOGETHER AND THAT
WHEN YOU BUILD MORE HOUSING
YOU SHOULD BE REWARDED WITH
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS BECAUSE
A LOT OF WHAT STOPS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS FROM BUILDING
HOUSING IN THE FIRST PLACE IS
THEY DON'T FEEL LIKE I DON'T
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT
TO SUPPORT THE INCREASED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE SO
WE ACTUALLY THINK THESE THINGS
WORK TOGETHER YOU DO HAVE A
GOOD POINT AND THAT DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS ARE DIFFERENT
AND COMMUNITIES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY HAVE DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES THANKS COMMITTEES
ON THE COAST AND THAT'S WHY
THE PRECURSOR TO ALL OF THIS
IS REVAMPING THE WAY THAT
WE SENT THESE HOUSING GOALS
BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY WANT THEM
TO MAKE SENSE AND WE BELIEVE
THAT ONCE THEY DO MAKE SENSE
DAN AND WE CAN LINK HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION TOGETHER AND
AND DO YOU HAVE A FORMULA AND
TERMS OF THESE GOALS ARE HOW
DO YOU DETERMINE THESE RICH
UNCLES THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE TO WORK OUT DON'T ONE
THING THAT WE DO KNOW IS THE
CURRENT REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE RIGHT NOW NEEDS
UPDATING OKAY -- JUMPING TO
THE MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT -- WE
HAVE A PROJECTIONS THAT -- THE
FUND IS GOING TO BE EXHAUSTED
-- BY TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
ONE TO OTHER ANY PLANS TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE SO IN THIS
IN THIS CURRENT IN THIS BUDGET
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
WE HAVEN'T PROPOSED ANY CHANGES
TO THE MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT NOW
OKAY BUT YOU ARE BUT -- I GUESS
THE FROM YOUR STANDPOINT I
MEAN THERE IS LIKE -- AWARENESS
THAT THE FUND IS PROJECTED TO
BE EXHAUSTED BY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO SO LET ME TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE TO
CERTAINLY MARK MILLER PARTNER
FINANCED YES WE ARE AWARE OF
THIS WORKING IN -- -- LOOK
AT THE -- THE FUNK ADDITION
SITUATION IN THE NBA IS PART
OF -- BROUGHT THE PROPER
DISCUSSION FOR OTHER ANY IDEAS
OUT THERE THAT YOU GUYS HAVE
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING AT WE'RE
LOOKING AT OPTIONS OKAY THE
THE VAST MAJORITY THE REVENUES
COME FROM REGISTRATION FEES
AND -- AND AND SOME OF THEM
FROM DRIVERS LICENSE FEES SO
NOT A LOT OF MOVING PARTS THEIR
SHARE A GOTCHA -- IN TERMS OF
THE LA -- -- IN TERMS OF THE
JUST SO THAT EVERYONE OPERATE
ON THE SAME INFORMATION WHAT
IS THE ESTIMATED UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES OF THE CITY
CALIFORNIA PENSION -- IN TERMS
OF PENSION LIABILITIES OUT
I'D HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
TO BREAK IT DOWN ACROSS THE
DIFFERENT FUNDS -- WHAT'S THE
TOTAL -- THE TOTAL HERE I THINK
I HAVE IT HERE SO FOR CALPERS
IT'S FIFTY NINE BILLION AND
FOR CAL STIRS IT'S A HUNDRED
AND FOUR AND BILLION DOLLARS
-- BUT THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE --
-- HEALTH CARE RETIREE HEALTH
CARE BENEFITS AND I HAVE TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON ON THE TO ABOUT
WHAT THAT WOULD BRING THE TOTAL
TO IN THAT ASSUMES A SEVEN
PERCENT RATE OF RETURN FOR
CAL'S SPURS YES CAL STIRS I'D
HAVE TO DOUBLE CHECK SO IN THE
MODELING THAT THAT YOU'VE DONE
IF EVER RECESSION DID OCCUR HOW
DOES THE STATE RESPOND TO THE
FUNDING THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY
SO WHAT WE DO IN TERMS OF OUR
RECESSION MODELING IS WE LOOK
AT -- WHETHER OR NOT BE --
REVENUES AND RESERVES WOULD
BE SUFFICIENT TO PAY FOR THE
ON GOING COSTS TO THE STATES
SO -- IN TERMS OF HOW THAT
INTERACTS WITH THE PENSION
LIABILITIES JUST NOT MUCH JUST
USE THE CALPERS EXAMPLE TO
THE EXTENT CALPERS EXPERIENCES
LOSSES BECAUSE WE'RE IN A
RECESSION AND THE MARKET GOES
DOWN CALPERS WOULD ADJUST THE
RATES THAT THE STATE HAS TO
PAY TO CALPERS WHICH WOULD
INCREASE OUR ONGOING COSTS
SO -- UNDER OUR MODELING FOR
SORT OF A YEAR TO YEAR BUDGET
SCENARIO WE DO TRY TO BUILD IN
HOW THOSE ONGOING COSTS CHANGE
AND WHAT THE COSTS OF THE STATE
WOULD BE IN TERMS OF ONGOING
PROGRAMMATIC COSTS INCLUSIVE
OF -- ODD SALARIES AND AND
AND PENSION PAYMENTS AND THAT
SORT OF THING BUT WE DON'T
MAKE ANY ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
PAYING DOWN INCREASED UNFUNDED
LIABILITY AS A RESULT OF A
MARKET DECLINE UPDATE IT TO THE
PIPELINE IS IT G.
IS YOUR NUMBERS QUICK TO YOUR
NUMBERS CORRELATE IN TERMS OF
UNFUNDED LIABILITIES THAT THE
STATE HAS YES WE'RE WORKING OFF
THE SAME SEVEN NUMBERS AND I
BELIEVE THE ON FUNDED RETIREE
HEALTH CARE LIABILITIES IS --
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
IS ESTIMATED MOST RECENTLY
AT NINETY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
NINETY ONE I'VE HEARD UP TO TO
ONE FIFTY SEVEN BILLION -- FOR
THIS IS JUST FOR THE -- PAD
MIGHT DEPEND ON WHAT DISCOUNT
RATE THAT YOU'RE USING BUT
THE TOTALED BUT THE OF ALL THE
SIX YES THAT'S CORRECT BECAUSE
IF YOU ADD UP THE NINETY ONE
BILLION THAT JUST A SHADE
OVER A HUNDRED BILLION FOR
CAL STIRS AND THEN THE FIFTY
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALPERS STATE PORTION OF THE
LIABILITY THAT SHOULD ADD UP TO
ABOUT THAT FIGURE OKAY SO THAT
SO THAT'S THE THAT'S THE COURT
THAT'S ME THAT'S THE TOTAL TO
THE SEVEN THAT WORK WOULD WERE
DRUNK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO GRAPPLE WITH YES I SHOULD
MENTION THAT AND I'M NOT SURE
IF MISS TO MENTION THIS BUT FOR
THE CALLOUSED ARE IS LIABILITY
THAT IS SPLIT BETWEEN THE
STATE AND THE SCHOOLS AND I
BELIEVE ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF
THAT RIGHT NOW IS ACTUALLY
BORN BY THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
RATHER THAN THE STATE YES
THANK YOU MISTER SWITCH TO
THE MISS JOHNSON THANK YOU
MISTER SHARE THANK YOU FOR
THAT -- WE ARE YOU KNOW
PEOPLE WANT TO ADD ON TO AB
SEVENTY TWO AND SEVENTY THREE
SO WE'RE GOING TO THAT FIRST
BROKE TO JONES SAWYER BY JONES
SAWYER I'D MAIENSCHEIN MULLIN
MULLIN AYE STONE STONE NINE
ICE TWENTY SEVEN THAT COULD
BE OUT ON TO THE RULES AS WELL
BRO TO TOOK HER SIERRA
CHRISSY I DON'T SAWYER JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY LACKEY
AYE THE MOMENT MAIENSCHEIN
MULLIN WILL AND I THIS AREA
NAZARIAN AYE PATTERSON WEBER
I TWENTY SIX THEY GIVE THIS
MESSAGE THANK YOU MISS SHARE
-- QUESTION FOR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE -- WANT TO -- --
CONVEY MY APPRECIATION -- AS AN
EXTENSION OF THE APPRECIATION
THAT I'VE BEEN HEARING FROM
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE FOR -- THE GOVERNOR
LISTENING TO THE CHALLENGES
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE FACING
-- ESPECIALLY IN THE AREAS OF
PENSION LIABILITIES AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION COSTS AND SO I I KNOW
THAT TO THERE ARE -- SPECIFIC
A ONE TIME PROPOSALS -- TO
ADDRESS -- THAT THE CHALLENGES
THAT MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE FACING -- HAVING SAID
THAT YOU KNOW -- ESPECIALLY
THOSE OF US COMING FROM LOS
ANGELES WE ARE JUST COMING
OUT OF A PERHAPS HISTORIC A
TEACHERS STRIKE THAT -- REALLY
GALVANIZED THE COMMUNITY AND
IS HIGHLIGHTING THE CHALLENGES
-- NOT ONLY FACING LAUSD BUT
-- OAKLAND UNIFIED SACRAMENTO
UNIFIED DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- THAT
-- ARE ARE SAYING THAT YOU KNOW
DESPITE THE -- THIS LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR BROWN'S --
-- TREMENDOUS EFFORTS AND
RESTORING FUNDING FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION
FINDING THAT -- -- THEY
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH THE
FACT THAT WHILE WE LIVE IN THE
WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
-- THAT WE ARE FORTY FIRST
IN THE NATION IN PER PEOPLE
SPENDING AND THIS AND ADEQUACY
OF STATE FUNDING FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE PUBLIC EDUCATION
CONTINUES TO BE YOU KNOW WERE
REFLECTED IN THE -- IT THAT
THE CHALLENGES THAT NOT ONLY
TEACHERS BUT FAMILIES -- IN
LOS ANGELES AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE -- ARE REALLY FOCUSING
ON THE THE OVERCROWDED CLASS
SIZES THE THE LACK OF NURSES
AND COUNSELORS AND AND SUPPORT
SERVICES AND SO MY QUESTION
TO -- TO YOU -- AND FOR THE
GOVERNOR IS DOES THE GOVERNOR
HAVE A PLAN TO GET CALIFORNIA
FROM BEING FORTY FIRST IN
THE NATION IN PER PEOPLE
SPENDING BACK TO WHERE WE ONCE
WERE IN THE TOP TEN IN THE
NATION IN PER PUPIL SPENDING
SO I WANT TO MAKE TWO POINTS
-- IN RESPONSE TO THAT THE
FIRST IS THAT THIS BUDGET
DOES PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL
TWO BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
AS YOU MENTIONED IT PROVIDES
THREE BILLION DOLLARS FOR CAL
STIRS OBLIGATIONS OF WHICH
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WILL FLOW DIRECTLY
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE YEAR FOLLOWING TO OFFER
RELIEF TO SCHOOLS AND ALSO
AND JESSICA HOMES CAN OFFER
MORE DETAIL ABOUT THIS BUT IT
SHIFTED SOME PRE K.
MONEY FOR NON LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES -- OUTSIDE OF THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEED
THEREBY CREATING MORE -- ROOM
THAT WE CAN USE FOR OTHER
PRIORITIES SUCH AS K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS SO WE DO THINK
THAT THIS IS A BIG COMMITMENT
IT'S THE HIGHEST EVER LEVEL --
THAT BEING SAD -- THERE WHEN IT
COMES TO EDUCATION WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE SO MUCH MORE WORK TO DO
AND THE KEY QUESTION IS REALLY
FINDING WAYS HOW TO DO THAT
IN THIS BUDGET WE THINK WE'VE
PROVIDED WHAT WE BELIEVE IS A
STRONG BASE FOR K.
TWELVE EDUCATION IN THE STATE
CONSISTENT WITH OUR OTHER
PRIORITIES WHEN IT COMES TO A
CHILD CARE AND EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT AND CAL WORKS IN
HIGHER EDUCATION WHERE WE ALSO
WANTED TO PROVIDE A STRONG
ON GOING INCREASE AFTER YEARS
WHEN THE SYSTEMS RECEIVED --
LAST AND THEY MIGHT HAVE WANTED
A ROSTER FOR -- BUT WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT WITH K.
TWELVE THERE IS A DEMAND FOR
MORE AND WE SAW THAT AS YOU
MENTION IN LOS ANGELES SO THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE WANT TO
HAVE WITH ALL OF YOU AS WELL
HOW WOULD WE FIND THE REVENUE
ON AN ONGOING BASIS TO DO THAT
BECAUSE AS YOU MENTIONED THESE
ARE ONGOING COSTS THAT WILL
OCCUR EVERY YEAR I MEAN IT'S
JUST -- I WOULD JUST ASK YOU
THAT -- -- DID THE GOVERNOR
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE YOU
KNOW RECOGNIZE THAT -- YOU
KNOW WHILE THERE IS MUCH IN
THIS BUT THE GOVERNOR'S INITIAL
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT WE ALL
APPRECIATE FROM EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION TO YOU KNOW TO THE
AT THE THE -- YOU KNOW MANY
OF THE ITEMS THAT -- THAT THAT
-- -- HAVE BEEN HIGHLIGHTED IN
THE IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
THAT YOU KNOW WE WE HAVE THESE
CORE -- -- OBLIGATIONS -- -- I
I BELIEVE THAT K.
THROUGH TWELVE OF FINDING A
CONTINUES TO BE THE STATE'S
NUMBER ONE FUNDING PRIORITY --
AND THAT -- YOU KNOW WE WE DID
HAVE -- AND AND TWENTY THIRTEEN
WE WE ESTABLISHED A PLAN TO
TO -- RESTORE CALIFORNIA'S --
CATER TO A BUDGET CUTS -- THAT
WE SUFFER DURING THE RECESSION
BY ESTABLISHING FUNDING TARGETS
-- YOU KNOW TO GET US FROM
FROM TWENTY THIRTEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND -- I I WOULD
URGE AND AND LOOK FORWARD
TO HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE GOVERNOR TO LOOK TO WIN A
WHAT IS NEXT IN TERMS OF OUR
LCF FUNDING TARGETS NOW THAT
WE HAVE REACHED THE FUNDING
TARGETS THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN -- SO IT
WILL LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
THAT CONVERSATION AND WE KNOW
THAT WE'VE COME A LONG WAY AS
YOU REMEMBER AT THE PEAK OF
THE RECESSION PROP NINETY EIGHT
LEVEL WAS DOWN TO ABOUT FORTY
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS AND NOW
WE'RE ABOUT EIGHTY BILLION
DOLLARS WE'VE ADDED ABOUT
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON A PER
PUPIL BASIS OVER THOSE SEVEN
OR EIGHT YEARS BUT WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S MUCH MORE TO DO YES
JUST SORT I AM JUST A DOCTOR
AND AND IN MY -- MY QUESTION
IS REALLY ABOUT A CRUEL JUSTICE
-- I KNOW WE'VE WE'VE DONE
A LOT WITH AB ONE OH NINE
PROP 47-57 -- BUT I'VE SAID
OVER AND OVER AGAIN -- ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION AND I DON'T
THINK WE'VE DONE A VERY GOOD
JOB IMPLEMENTATION AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE HAVE USED -- -- OUR
INABILITY TO EFFECTIVELY --
TO REHABILITATION WHETHER IT'S
FORCES INSIDE OR OUTSIDE WHO
DIDN'T WANT TO DO IT SABOTAGE
UNIT OR WE NOT KNOWING WHAT
TO DO AND HOW TO IMPLEMENT
IT AND SOMETIMES JUST PLAIN
INCOMPETENCE -- IS CREATED
-- A SITUATION WHERE PEOPLE
ARE WEAPONIZED OUR INABILITY
TO -- TO TO ACHIEVE THE KIND
OF SUCCESS WOULD BE ABILITY
ASIAN THAT WE NEED -- I LIKE
IN THAT TO YOU KNOW YOU RUN
THE FOOTBALL DOWN TO WIN THE
SUPERBOWL YOU FUMBLE ON THE
ON THE GOAL LINE OR YOU DECIDE
INSTEAD OF USING A CALIFORNIA
KID TO RUN BE SMALLER UP TO
MIDDLE YOU CYCLE PASSABLE NAPA
NEW ENGLAND PATRIOTS INTERCEPT
THE BALL AS THE ASSEMBLY MEN
OF THE LOS ANGELES RAMS WITH A
YOU CAN APPRECIATE
HOW DISCONCERTING THAT
WOULD BE IF THAT WERE TO
HAPPEN ANYTIME SOON --
BUT SERIOUSLY THE THE THE
GOVERNOR HAS TOLD ME HE WANTED
TO LOOK AT REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
AND I'M UNBELIEVABLE PLEASE
DAIS TAKEN -- DJJ OUT OF CDC
ART AND AS A PUT IN HUMAN
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES SO
THAT WE GET THEM TO TYPE THE
HELP THAT WE HAD WITH IT THE
NEED THE MOST IMPORTANT I
WANTED TO BE ABLE TO SUCCEED
AND DO YOU KNOW IF WE HAVE
A PLAN ON HOW WE'RE GOING
TO IMPLEMENT THAT AND THEN
THE SECOND PART OF THAT -- I
HAVEN'T AUDIT RIGHT NOW LOOKING
AT ALL OF THE -- REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS NCDC ARW THAT OUGHT
IS COMPLETED AND IT WILL BE --
PRESENTED THIS WEEK AND WILL
HAVE A KIND OF A A LOOK AT THE
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS WHAT
WORKS WHAT DOESN'T WORK AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN WORK TOGETHER
WITH THE GOVERNOR OF TO MOVE
ON TO PRESENT THE MOST AFFECTED
PROGRAMS AND BE QUITE FRANK
WITH YOU OF THE ONES THAT DON'T
WORK TO MY STATE KIND OF JUST
CREE BUSY WORK -- WE MOVE THAT
FUNDING FROM THEM INTO THE
MOST EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT --
PROGRAMS SO IT'S KIND OF A TWO
FOLD QUESTION -- I'M EXCITED
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH DJJ
BUT I'M I'M A LITTLE WORRIED
ABOUT OUR IMPLEMENTATION
PROGRAM IF WE HAVE ONE WE HAVE
ANY IDEAS OF WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO AND HOW WE CAN MAKE THAT
HAPPEN AND THEN THE SECOND
PART -- AS WE MOVE FORWARD HOW
WE'RE GOING TO IMPROVE THE REAL
BILL TATIAN PROGRAM AND CDC
ARE HOW WE CAN PARTNER WITH
THE LEGISLATURE SO WE CAN MOVE
QUICKLY TO ENSURE THAT IS THE
MOST EFFECTIVE UP PROGRAM --
THAT WE COULD HAVE ABSOLUTELY
SO A COUPLE POINTS I WANT TO
MAKE FIRST IS YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT THAT WE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS OVER THE LAST EIGHT
YEARS UNDER AB ONE OH NINE AND
REDUCE THE STATE POPULATION
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED
BY AROUND THIRTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE AND WE'RE EXPECTING
WITH PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN
THAT SEVERAL ADDITION --
SEVERAL THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED
WILL BE RELEASED UNDER THAT
PROGRAM FOR CREDITS AND GOOD
BEHAVIOR BUT THAT BEING SAID
AS YOU NOTED WE DON'T WANT TO
FUMBLE ON THE GOAL LINE AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE GETTING THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS THAT THEY NEED AND
SO WE NOTICED IN THIS BUDGET
WHEN YOU TRACK OVER THE LAST
SIX OR SEVEN YEARS THE LEVEL
FUNDING FOR REHABILITATION IS
OVER A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
OF BONDS WHAT IT WAS IN TWENTY
TWELVE AND TWENTY THIRTEEN BUT
YOUR POINT EXACTLY IT'S ONE
THING TO SPEND THE MONEY BUT
IT'S ANOTHER TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S BEING SPENT WHILE AND THE
GOVERNOR IS VERY INTENTIONAL
ABOUT THIS HE HAS THIS PHRASE
IS NOT JUST ABOUT RESOURCES
IT'S ABOUT RESOURCEFULNESS AND
IT APPLIES HERE PERHAPS MORE
THAN ANY OTHER AREA SO I KNOW
THAT'S A CONVERSATION THAT
WE WILL WANT TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE WITH YOUR OFFICE AND WHEN
IT COMES SPECIFICALLY TO HIS
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS HE'S
VERY INVESTED IN LITERACY AND
THIS BUDGET INCLUDES ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR LITERACY COACHES
IN OUR PRISONS INCLUDING PEOPLE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED COACHING
OTHER PEOPLE AND HELPING THEM
LEARN TO READ BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR AND OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVE
THAT HELPING PEOPLE TO READ --
CASCADES AND SO MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS AND HELPING THEM GET
OPPORTUNITIES WHEN THEY GET OUT
BUT THE LAST AND MOST IMPORTANT
THING I WANT TO SAY IS THAT
WHEN THE AUDIT IS FINISHED --
WE WOULD LOVE TO HEAR -- THOSE
RESULTS AND SHARE THEM WITH
ACROSS THE ADMINISTRATION AND
CONTINUE TO SEE HOW WE CAN WORK
WITH YOU TECH THANK YOU THANKS
THANK YOU DOCTOR REGULAR THE
MIST BLOW THANK YOU MISS JUST
READ US THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
-- YOU KNOW I'VE HEARD IT SAID
THAT YOU CAMPAIGN IN POETRY BUT
YOU GOVERN IN PROSE AND I WAS
QUITE ANXIOUS TO SEE AND READ
EVERY WORD OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT HE PROPOSED ON
JANUARY I WAS ENCOURAGED
THAT HE IS DELIVERING ON HIS
CAMPAIGN PROMISES AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE AND CALIFORNIA ARE
ABLE TO FOLLOW THE MODEL THAT
DOCTOR WOULD AND I LED LAST
YEAR IN TERMS OF OUR SELECT
COMMITTEE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
UNIVERSAL HEALTH COVERAGE
I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT SOME
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT WERE
PROPOSED IN THIS BUDGET THAT
I PARTICULARLY BELIEVE WILL
HELP PUT US ON THE RIGHT PATH
AND JUST WANTS TO APPLAUD THIS
ADMINISTRATION FOR LISTENING
TO THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
AND HELPING THOSE OF US WHO
COME FROM BLUE COLLAR DISTRICTS
HELP TO DELIVER REAL RESULTS
WE HAVE A WAY TO DIFFERENTIATE
OURSELVES FROM WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN OUR NATIONAL RHETORIC AND
HELP LEAD TOWARDS A NEW DEAL
IN OUR GOVERNOR IS PUTTING
US ON A PATH DOING JUST THAT
THE HUNDRED AND FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT HE PUT INTO EARLY
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY HAS
PUSHED AS WELL AS HE SAID IS
THAT WE HAVE PUSHED TOGETHER
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A SURGEON
GENERAL AND THE EXCELLENT
CHOICE OF DOCTOR NADINE BURKE
HARRIS WHO WE WERE PLEASED
TO BRING TO THE CAPITAL LAST
YEAR TO HAVE A WOMAN OF COLOR
AND PARTICULARLY SOMEONE
WHO UNDERSTANDS THE EFFECTS
OF TRAUMA WILL GET US THE
RESOURCEFULNESS AND RESILIENCY
TO WHICH YOU WERE JUST SPEAKING
ABOUT INCREASING TO HOME
VISITING AND ALLOWING US TO GET
INTO PEOPLE'S HOMES AND TO HELP
NEW PARENTS ACHIEVE IS A GREAT
PROGRAM AND ONE THAT WE'VE
BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF US WELL I'M
PARTICULARLY IMPRESSED WITH HIS
ABILITY TO ENCOURAGE MANAGEMENT
OF CHRONIC DISEASE AND TO SEE
THE INTEGRATION WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH THERE'S THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
THIS BUDGET THAT WILL HELP US
TO DO JUST THAT DOCTOR WOULD
HAS INTRODUCED A BILL TO LOOK
AT SUBSIDIES THAT WILL ALSO
AFFECT NOT JUST THE ACCESS TO
CARE BUT THE IN AFFORDABILITY
OF CARE WE SHOULDN'T HAVE A
PLAN IN HEALTH CARE WHICH IS
DON'T GET SEC PEOPLE WILL HAVE
A CRISIS AND ISSUES IN THEIR
LIVES AND WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW HEALTH CARE CAN BE
AFFORDABLE FOR THE VAST MIDDLE
CLASS IN OUR STATE WHO DOES
NOT HAVE THAT CURRENT ABILITY
AND YES I AM QUITE EXCITED
THAT WHEN HE SAID THAT EVERYONE
IN CALIFORNIA DESERVES HEALTH
CARE THAT HE MEANT EVERYONE
AND WHILE WE HAVE TAKEN OUR
FIRST STEPS THIS YEAR THERE
WILL BE MORE ADVOCACY TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN CONTINUE TO TAKE
CARE OF THOSE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND I HAVE A PARTICULAR SPOT
REALLY LOOKING AT THE ELDERS
WITHIN MANY OF OUR CULTURES AND
COMMUNITIES IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE TAKE CARE OF THOSE WHO HAVE
GIVEN SO MUCH TO US AND REALLY
WOULD WANT US TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION AND
FINALLY I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT BEING ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE INCREASE OUR SAFETY
NET RESERVE FUND SO WE DON'T
ENTER INTO THE PARADOX WHICH
OCCURS WHEN WE WILL HAVE OUR
NEXT RECESSION WILL PROVIDE
US THE BUDGET RESILIENCY TO
CONTINUE TO MEET THE DEMANDS
OF THOSE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
FINALLY I JUST WANT TO TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HUMAN
SERVICES BECAUSE THAT'S STILL
IN SOME OF THE JURISDICTION
THAT WE WORK ON BUT WORKING
TO END CHILDHOOD POVERTY AND
GETTING US TO FIFTY PERCENT OF
CAL WORKS IS A NOBLE GOAL AND
WANTS TO FOLLOW UP WITH THE
LA -- IF I CAN ON SPECIFICALLY
HOW DOING IT ACROSS THE BOARD
DOESN'T GET CERTAIN FAMILIES
TO THAT GOAL MAKING CASH OUT
PERMANENT IS A NOBLE GOAL ONE
THAT WE HELPED TO CHAMPION LAST
YEAR AND ONE THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
HELP THOSE WHO ARE DISABLED WHO
ARE ELDERLY AND HAVE NEEDS BE
ABLE TO MAKE THEIR ENDS MEET
I WANTED TO AND IF I COULD
ACTUALLY ON A QUESTION WE HAD
TALKED ABOUT MCO TAX BUT I
WAS SURPRISED THAT IT WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE DISCUSSION
AND AND I'M WONDERING WHAT
THE LOGIC IS TO NOT CONTINUE
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN IN
EFFECT FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS AND WHAT THE CURRENT
THINKING OF THE ADMINISTRATION
IS IN -- IN THAT FRAME AND
HOW WE CAN CONTINUE TO LOOK
TOWARDS THE ONE BILLION DOLLARS
IN GENERAL FUND SAVINGS THAT
IT WOULD PROVIDE THROUGH THE
MCO TAX AND UNDERSTAND THE
THINKING OF THE ADMINISTRATION
CAROLINE YOU WANNA TALK ABOUT
CAL WORKS AND THEN WE CAN
SEE I TALK OFF LINE IF WE CAN
ON CAL WORKS SUCH A GREAT OF
SURE SOUNDS GOOD SO ON THE
NCO TAX WHEN WE WERE PUTTING
TOGETHER THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
IN NOVEMBER AND DECEMBER AND
AS YOU KNOW IN AN ELECTION
YEAR THE GOVERNOR BASICALLY
AFTER HERE SHE'S ELECTED HAS
ABOUT SIX OR SEVEN WEEKS TO
PUT TOGETHER THIS IN THIS CASE
TWO HUNDRED NINE BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET WE WERE UNCERTAIN ABOUT
WHETHER THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WOULD APPROVE THE WAIVER THAT'S
NECESSARY FOR A CONTINUATION
OF THE NCO TAX -- SINCE THEN
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME SIGNALS THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MAY BE
MORE LIKELY TO APPROVED SUCH
A WAIVER THAN WE OTHERWISE
MAY I THOUGHT WITH THAT BEING
SAID -- WE BUILT OUR BUDGET
WE THINK IT'S A GOOD BUDGET
-- AND WE BUILT IT WITHOUT
THAT AND CO TAX EXTENDING PAST
JULY SO WE THOUGHT WE'D FIND
EVERYTHING THAT WE NEEDED AND
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL WAIVERS
THAT WERE NEGOTIATING OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND WE WANTED TO
PLACE A PRIORITY ON THOSE
WAIVERS THAT SAID WE KNOW THAT
MANY MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
ARE INTERESTED IN THE
CONTINUATION OF THIS TAX AND
WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
YOUR FEEDBACK ON THAT YEAH YOU
MAY HAVE NOTICED THEIR SIXTY
ONE OF US NOW WITHIN OUR CAUCUS
MANY MORE OF US ON THIS BUDGET
CHAIR SUCH THAT WE'VE HAD TO
CHANGE THE SIZE OF THE SEATS
AND AND ALL WE MUST FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MAINTAIN FISCAL
DISCIPLINE WE ALSO NEED TO
THEY'RE AT SO I REALLY DO HOPE
WE CAN HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
-- I DID WANT TO HAVE ONE FINAL
QUESTION AND THAT'S ACTUALLY
REGARDING THE -- PROPOSAL
REGARDING PRESCRIPTIONS -- I'M
INTERESTED TO HAVE A LITTLE
BIT MORE MEAT ON THAT BONE
AND TO UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE
PROPOSAL IS -- WE AS A STATE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN NEGOTIATING
POWER OF THE THIRD OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND JUST REALLY
I'M HOPING YOU CAN ELUCIDATE
SOME OF THE -- -- IDEAS OR
IDEALS THAT WE CAN BE STRIVING
FOR -- WITH THAT PROPOSAL
IT'S ALL MAKE TWO POINTS ON
THAT PROPOSAL IT'S CLEARLY A
PRIORITY OF THE ADMINISTRATION
THE GOVERNOR AND HIS FIRST OR
SECOND DAY IN OFFICE SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER DIRECTING THE
REST THE GOVERNMENT TO MOVE
FORWARD TOWARD THAT PROPOSAL
AND THE REASON HE DID IT SO
EARLY IS NOT ONLY BECAUSE IT'S
SO IMPORTANT BUT BECAUSE IT
WILL TAKE TIME A PROPOSAL OF
THIS MAGNITUDE AFFECTING THIS
MANY MILLIONS OF PEOPLE SO
THE WAY WE'RE ESTIMATING IT
RIGHT NOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THEIR THEIR TWO MAJOR
PROBLEMS THIS PROPOSAL ONE IS
TO TRANSFER THAT MEDICAID OR
MEDICARE AL -- BENEFIT TO A
FEE FOR SERVICE BENEFIT FOR
PHARMACY THAT'S MANAGED ACROSS
THE POPULATION AND NOT SIMPLY
MANAGED CARE PLAN BY MANAGED
CARE PLANS AND SAID THAT WOULD
PUT THIRTEEN MILLION PEOPLE
SOME ODD IN THAT SAME POOL
AND WOULD MAKE OUR NEGOTIATING
LEVERAGE MUCH STRONGER WHEN
IT COMES TO NEGOTIATING THESE
DRUGS NOW HOW WE DO THAT AND
THE CONTOURS OF A THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
NOT ONLY HAS TO WORK OUT IN
TERMS OF WHAT'S THE SMARTEST
PROPOSAL BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
GET A SENSE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OF WHAT WE ARE ABLE
AND NOT ABLE TO DO AND THAT
WILL BE AN ONGOING NEGOTIATIONS
THAT WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT AND
THEN THE SECOND PART OF IT IS
THE CALIFORNIA PHARMACEUTICAL
COLLABORATE AS AND THIS IS
OTHER ORGANISER OTHER ENTITIES
WITHIN CALIFORNIA STATE
GOVERNMENT WHETHER IT'S IT'S
EGS OR YOU KNOW CORRECTION
IN OTHER OTHER GROUPS THAT --
CAN BAND TOGETHER AND AGAIN
GET THE LEVERAGE THAT COMES
FROM STRENGTH IN NUMBERS AND
SO WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING THERE IS MAKING A
WEST OF SOME OF THE HIGHEST
COST MOST USED DRUGS AND
SEEING WHERE WE CAN NEGOTIATE
AND REDUCE THOSE COSTS BUT
I WILL SAY THAT ACROSS THIS
INITIATIVE IN OUR BUDGET WE'RE
SITTING HERE IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY NINETEEN -- WE DON'T
EXPECT SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS FOR
NOT THIS YEAR NOT NEXT YEAR
AND REALLY NOT IN MANY WAYS
THE YEAR AFTER IT REALLY ONLY
STARTS TO KICK IN AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE LATER IN THE YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
THREE IN ON WORDS AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE SEEING THE BENEFITS
OF THIS IS VERY COMPLICATED WE
KNOW WE HAD ISSUES WITH SOME
COMMUNITY HOSPITALS RELATED
TO THREE FORTY B.
SO WE WANT TO START EARLY
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
TO GET THIS RIGHT YEAH WE'VE
HEARD THAT HEALTHCARE IS
COMPLICATED BUT YES NOBODY
HERE HAS THE PRESIDENT SAID
IF YOU CAN HELP US JUST TO
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE TOWARDS
THIS ADMINISTRATION HE REALLY
IS SHOWING LEADERSHIP AND
HEALTH CARE AND I'M QUITE
PLEASED THAT HE IS BECOMING
THE HEALTH CARE GOVERNOR THAT
MANY OF US HOPED AND WISHED
THAT HE WOULD INSPIRED TO
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER AND
MISS RIVERS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- AT -- WELCOME IT'S
GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE -- I'D
LIKE TO BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO -- ANOTHER -- TOPIC
THAT THE GOVERNOR SHOWN GREAT
LEADERSHIP ON AND THAT IS
SO HOUSING THE -- PROPOSAL
FOR SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS YOU MENTION WAS
BROKEN DOWN TO FIFTY MILLION
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE --
WHAT THEN IS THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION INTENDED TO BE USED
FOR SO THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IS INCENTIVE GRANTS
FOR JURISDICTIONS THAT MEET
THEIR MILESTONES SO ONE OF THE
CORNERSTONES OF OUR HOUSING
POLICIES WE CAN GIVE MONEY TO
FOR JURISDICTIONS TO DIRECTLY
BELLHOUSING ACTUALLY FUND A
HOUSING AND THEIR WAYS IN WHICH
THE STATE DOES THAT WE CAN
GET MONEY FOR THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AROUND BUILDING
THE HOUSING THAT'S THINGS LIKE
ZONING PERMITTING STAFFING TO
MAKE THOSE ACTIVITIES HAPPENED
BUT ANOTHER THING THAT WE
RECOGNIZE IS A LOT OF THESE
JURISDICTIONS -- THERE IS AN
INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO LOOK
FOR MORE REVENUE AND WE ALL
KNOW HOW HARD IT IS FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO RAISE REVENUE
IN CALIFORNIA SO PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S THINKING
WAS THAT IN ADDITION TO THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO HELP
THEM ACHIEVE THESE GOALS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ALSO
HAVE A POT OF MONEY SO THAT
WHEN THOSE JURISDICTIONS TO
STEP UP AND THEY TO DO THE
RIGHT THING TAKING AT ACCESS
TO THIS FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR MARKET AND MAKING USE
THAT FOR ANY GOALS THAT THEY
HAVE IT DOESN'T EVEN HAVE TO
BE HOUSING SO WE WANT TO WORK
JURISDICTIONS THAT DO THE RIGHT
THING AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY HAVE OTHER PRIORITIES AS
WELL AND IF YOU STEP UP IN THIS
AREA YOU'LL HAVE MORE RESOURCES
TO DO MORE IN OTHER AREAS TOO
OKAY I THINK I I THINK THAT'S
VERY INTERESTING AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING MORE ABOUT
IT -- AND I DO THINK THAT IT'S
A GOOD IDEA TO BE INCENTIVIZING
OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO DO
MORE THE GOVERNOR -- CLEARLY
IS USING A CARROT AND STICK
APPROACH -- WE'VE READ A LOT
ABOUT THE THE STICK IN THE
NEWSPAPER IN RECENT RECENT
DAYS -- AND I THINK ALL THIS
IS WORTHY OF -- OF -- OF
DISCUSSION MOVING FORWARD ON --
-- ONE THINK -- -- THEN I THINK
ALSO NEEDS TO BE CONSIDERED
IS FINDING WAYS TO LOWER THE
COST OF CONSTRUCTION OF BOTH
AFFORDABLE AND TO A MARKET RATE
HOUSING BECAUSE OF ONE OF THE
GREAT CHALLENGES WE FACE IS
THAT THE COST OF CONSTRUCTION
OF THE UNIT OF FOR EXAMPLE A
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS IN THE
RANGE OF A HALF MILLION DOLLARS
PER UNIT OR SO AND SO THERE'S A
LOT OF MONEY -- -- IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S BEEN --
APPROVED AND IN THE -- A STATE
BUDGET THAT'S BEEN APPROVED FOR
FOR HOUSING CONSTRUCTION BUT IT
ONLY GOES SO FAR SEE YOU HAVE A
BILLION DOLLAR SEA AND -- -- --
FINDING IT SOUNDS LIKE A LOT OF
MONEY BUT IT ONLY BUILT ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND UNITS AT A TIME
WHEN WE NEED FAR MORE THAN THAT
AND THEN THE OTHER ISSUE IS
-- -- FINDING WAYS TO -- -- A
SPEND NOT ONLY SPEND THAT MONEY
EFFICIENTLY BUT -- -- CHEN
UPPER ABILITY THERE TO TO BUILD
IT QUICKLY -- OF ONE OF THE --
ELEMENTS OF THE CRISIS THAT ARE
NOT BEING MET THE GOVERNOR'S
SPOKEN ABOUT THIS IS -- -- THE
INCREDIBLE PRESSURE THAT --
OF PEOPLE RENTAL HOUSING OR
FEELING GOT WITH RESPECT TO
THEIR -- IS TO THE RENTS AND
-- WE NEED TO TAKE ACTION ON
THAT BUT WE NEED TO GET UNITS
ONLINE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
SO THAT WE CAN MODERATE THE
-- -- IN AN INCREASE IN COST
BY -- INCREASING THE SUPPLY
OF HOUSING OUT THERE -- AND
I DON'T SEE ANY MONEY IN THE
BUDGET FOR THAT TO KIND OF
-- -- THING AND -- -- I'D
LIKE THAT TO BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION GOING ON ARMS OF
A LASTING ON HOUSING I WANTED
TO -- ASK YOU ABOUT -- IS THAT
YOU MENTIONED TO REVAMPING
THE RENEWAL PROCESS -- THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE DID IN AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE LAST YEAR
WHY DO I KNOW THAT THAT WAS
MY BILL -- SO I'M INTERESTED
IN KNOWING WHAT ELSE -- THE
GOVERNOR IS LOOKING AT IN TERMS
OF -- OF IMPROVING -- -- THAT
PROCESS AND I'M INTERESTED IN
FURTHERING THAT CONVERSATION
YOU'RE WELCOME TO PROVIDE
SOME -- LIMITED RESPONSE TO
THAT NOW BUT THIS IS MORE IN
THE NATURE OF ASK YOU THESE
QUESTIONS SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS GOING
FORWARD THAN THAT -- I'LL HAVE
ANOTHER QUESTION ON -- -- --
FIRE -- ABSOLUTELY I'LL MAKE
A TWO OR THREE VERY QUICK
POINTS -- BEFORE MOVING ON FOR
FIRE THE FIRST IS THAT AS YOU
NOTED AT THE BEGINNING THERE'S
DEFINITELY NO EASY SOLUTION TO
THIS HOUSING CRISIS IT'S NOT
GONNA BE FIXED WITH IT FIX WITH
A COUPLE BILLION DOLLARS THE
GOOD NEWS FOR THIS YEAR IS WE
HAVE LAST YEAR BOTH ARE FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR OVERALL HOUSING
BOND THAT WAS APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS YET THE TWO BILLION
DOLLAR NO PLACE LIKE HOME
BOND THAT WAS APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS IN NOVEMBER FOR PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
TO HELP THEM WITH HOUSING WE
ALSO HAVE THE ONGOING SOURCE
OF FUNDING FROM REAL ESTATE
TRANSACTIONS THAT WAS APPROVED
TWO YEARS AGO SO WE'RE HOPING
THAT OUR FUNDING LAYERED ON
TOP OF THOSE WILL START TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THE SECOND
THING AND YOU MAKE A REALLY
GOOD POINT HERE ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT WE REWARD EFFORTS
THAT ARE REDUCING THE COST
PER UNIT AND MAKING SURE THAT
THESE UNITS ARE BUILT QUICKLY
AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
ABOUT HOW TO GET THE BEST
IDEAS INTO OUR POLICY BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY THE CASE THAT NOT ALL
OF OUR HOUSING POLICIES IN THIS
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT MORE TO BE WORKED
OUT IN THE MONTHS TO COME AND
EVEN THE ITEMS THAT ARE IN THIS
BUDGET WHEN IT COMES TO HOW
WERE AWARDING SOMETHING YOU
FINDING THAT WERE GIVING OR
WE'RE PROPOSING THE EXPANSION
OF TAX CREDITS FOR HOUSING --
WHEN THOSE CREDITS ARE AWARDED
AND WHO GETS WHAT MONEY IN WINE
THOSE CAN ALL BE A FUNCTION
OF SOME OF THE GOALS THAT WERE
TRYING TO REFINE RIGHT NOW AND
EVEN THE DESIGN OF THE CURRENT
TAX CREDIT THAT THEY GENERALLY
CAN APPLY TO TAX CREDIT AFTER
THE PROJECT IS COMPLETED SO
WE HAVE SOME INCENTIVES IN
THERE ALREADY BUT AS YOU NOTED
IT'S CLEARLY NOT ENOUGH SO
WE WANT TO DO MORE AND LASTLY
ON EVERY NOW AND WE KNOW THAT
YOU'VE BEEN INVOLVED ON THAT
ISSUE SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE WANT TO WORK ON YOU WITH
THANK YOU FOR THIS
I I JUST I DO HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION MISTER SHARE ON
-- -- ON THE ISSUE OF --
OF FIRE PREVENTION AND -- I
THINK THAT THERE ARE GOVERNOR
-- MAKE SIGNIFICANT VERY
IMPORTANT INVESTMENTS AND
FIRE PREVENTION OF FOREST
HEALTH AND I'M GLAD TO SEE
THOSE AND WILL BE WORKING
ON THOSE AND -- IN BUDGET
SUB THREE -- BUT FOUR OUT OF
FIVE FIRES SO ORIGINATED ARE
URBAN POPULATED AREAS AND THEN
MIGRATE THROUGH -- POPULATED
AREAS SO I'M WONDERING IF
THERE'S ANY -- UP A FUNDING
PLAN TO HELP WITH HARDENING
HOMES AND AND ENSURING THAT
HOMEOWNERS OR -- -- ABLE TO
CREATE DEFENSIBLE SPACES --
FOR A FUTURE THAT WE KNOW LIES
AND SHALL MAKE ONE POINT AND
THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE THAT AS WELL WHICH
IS THAT WE WERE DISCUSSING
PHARMACEUTICAL EXACT ORDER
WAS THE GOVERNOR SIGNED ON THE
FIRST DAY OF HIS ADMINISTRATION
ON THE SECOND DAY HE SIGNED
A SERIES OF EXECUTIVE ORDERS
FOR WAYS TO FIRES AND ONE OF
THEM WAS TO ASK CAL FIRE TO
COME BACK WITHIN FORTY FIVE
DAYS A WITH SOME -- PROPOSED
MEASURES FOR HOW WE CAN ENGAGE
IN THESE HARDENING ACTIVITIES
AND MAKE SURE THAT COMMITTEES
ARE PROTECTED SO WHERE ABOUT
TWENTY TWO DAYS AND SO WE'RE
HALFWAY ON THAT CLOCK BUT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ADOPTING
THAT MUCH OF THE WORK THAT WE
DO AND NOT GIVE ANYTHING ELSE
TO SAY YES SIR THANK YOU MATT
ALL ME DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
SO AS YOU ALLUDED TO THE FIRE
PREVENTION GRANTS -- CONSISTENT
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF -- SB
-- NINE OH ONE DEMONSTRATION
CONTINUES THE COMMITMENT TO
-- TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR FIRE PREVENTION ACTIVITIES
THOSE ARE REALLY GEARED TOWARD
-- PROJECTS THAT PROTECT US
KIT COMMUNITY SCALE PROJECTS
WHICH WOULD BENEFIT COMMUNITIES
AS A WHOLE AS WELL AS THE
INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS TO RESIDE
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY WE THINK
THAT'S A STRATEGIC -- WAY TO
GO ABOUT FIRE PREVENTION AND
ALSO JUST MENTION THAT -- CAL
FIRES INDICATED THAT NINETY
FIVE PERCENT OF FIRES ARGUMENT
BECAUSE -- BUT THAT DOESN'T
I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHERE THE
FOUR OUT OF FIVE OF THE FIRES
ORIGINATING IN URBAN -- DATA
COMES FROM STUFF LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOU ONE KIND OF THAT DATA
POINTS OUT IT'S IN MY NOTES
STAFF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU THREE OF US THE BEST
MCCARTY DR I THINK THAT
THIS PROPOSED BUDGET MAKES
A CLEAR STATEMENT THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION
IS REALLY PREPARED TO TAKE
ON SOME CRITICAL ISSUES SUCH
AS AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
EDUCATION AND HEALTH CARE --
ON THAT POINT I'D LIKE TO FOCUS
ON COMMENTS OF THE LA -- --
SPECIFICALLY -- YOU NOTED THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S HOUSING PROPOSAL
SPREAD LIMITED RESOURCES TO A
BROADER INCOME LEVELS INCLUDING
MIDDLE INCOME CALIFORNIANS
OR THE MISSING MIDDLE AS
THE GOVERNOR IS CALLING THEM
YOU KNOW I'M A MEMBER THAT
REPRESENTS A DISTRICT THAT
CONTAINS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF WHAT WE'RE CALLING THE
HEAD IN HOMELESS FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN THEIR LIVING TRIPLED
UP IN GARAGES MOTELS OUR CARS
AND I'M REALLY INTERESTED IN
HAVING YOU EXPAND ON THOSE
COMMENTS SURE SO SO WE RAISE
THIS POINT ONLY TO RAISE A
LEGISLATOR THE LEGISLATURE THE
TRADE OFF -- ASSOCIATED WITH
MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT HOW
TO ALLOCATE LIMITED RESOURCES
FOR HOUSING -- SO UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL I I BELIEVE
IT'S FIVE THERE'S FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE MIDDLE
INCOME HOUSING LOAN PROGRAM --
THAT THAT'S AN EXPANSION FROM
I THINK IT WAS ABOUT FORTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS FROM
WHEN IT WAS FIRST ESTABLISHED
THAT PROGRAM TARGETS A
RELATIVELY HIGHER INCOME GROUP
OF INDIVIDUALS FOR HOUSING
ASSISTANCE UNDER CURRENT
RESOURCES THERE IF I'M IF I
HAVE MY FAX -- IF I HAVE MY
DATA POINTS CORRECT -- THERE'S
ONLY SUFFICIENT FUNDING FOR
ABOUT A QUARTER OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA'S RECEIVE SOME TYPE
OF HOUSING ASSISTANCE SO THREE
QUARTERS OF OF CALIFORNIANS
THERE ISN'T RESOURCES TO TO TO
HELP THEM SOMEONE ALLOCATING
AMONG LIMITED RESOURCES
ALBEIT A SIGNET A LARGE BUDGET
SIGNIFICAN BUDGET BUT STILL
LIMITED BUDGET WE JUST RAISE
THE LEGISLATURE HOW WOULD IT
LIKE TO PRIORITIZE WHO TO HELP
SURE THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS GO TO -- RELATIVELY
-- HIGHER INCOME INDIVIDUALS
OR WITH THE LEGISLATURE RATHER
PRIORITIZE THE LOWEST INCOME
CALIFORNIANS OR SPREAD THE
ASSISTANCE ACROSS A BROADER
GROUP THAT'S REALLY THE
THE THE -- RIGHT BEHIND THE
ISSUE THAT WE REYES THANK YOU
KNOW THIS IS AN AREA I THINK
THAT -- I'M VERY INTERESTED
TO CONTINUE TO DISCUSS
AND DECIDING WHERE THOSE
RESOURCES WILL BE ALLOCATED
AND YOU KNOW MY PRIORITY
IS TO FOCUS ON THE HIDDEN
HIDDEN HOMELESS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY
DOCTOR WHAT THANK YOU FIRST
FOR THE LA OKAY COUPLE THINGS
ABOUT REVENUES IN K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS SO AS MR
MURATSUCHI NOTED WE'VE HAD A
GREAT -- FIVE YEAR RUN WE'VE
INCREASED SCHOOL FUNDING BY
ROUGHLY FIFTY PERCENT BUT
WE'RE STILL THE BOTTOM TEN
STATES THE NATION AND NUMBER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE TEARING
-- SO THE PROPOSAL THIS YEAR
WE DO WE DO HAVE SOME MONEY
IN THE HEALTH PROGRAM PRETTY
MUCH COLA NOT THE GROWTH LIKE
THIS ON PRIOR YEARS YEAH BUT
THE ONE TIME INVESTMENT WILL
MAKE A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE
GRANTED LAUSD INSECTS CITY
ARE TRYING TO SEE EXACTLY
WHAT THAT MEANS TO THEIR CASH
FLOW PROBLEMS AND BUDGETARY
ISSUES I WANTED TO TO WRITE
SOMETHING THAT IN HERE YOU
SAY IS THAT THE POTENTIAL WITH
THE ENROLLMENT AND DECLINING
ENROLLMENT THAT WITH WITH THAT
CURRENT CURRENT YEAR REVENUES
COMING IN AND PROJECTIONS AND
AND THAT POTENTIALLY THE NAY
REVISED -- -- ALLOCATION FOR
OUR SCHOOLS COULD BE WHERE
AT POTENTIALLY LOWER YES SURE
-- SO THERE IT IS POSSIBLE
THAT THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE WILL DECLINE
-- ONCE WE HIT MAY IN PART
BECAUSE OF -- LOWER REVENUES
THE OTHER ISSUE HAPPENING
WITHIN THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE IS THAT THERE
ARE SOME COSTS THAT LIKELY
WILL NEED TO BE INCORPORATED
INTO THE GUARANTEE IN MAY
THAT ARE REFLECTED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SO THE AMOUNT
OF AVAILABLE RESOURCES FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THE LCF OF COLA
LIKELY WILL BE SMALLER AND MAY
YES IT'S -- AGAIN THE BIG
PICTURE WHAT ARE FINANCE
RECTOR WAS TALKING TO MR
MARTZ WHICH ABOUT EARLIER WALL
GREAT NEWS OVERALL LAST FEW
YEARS AND POSITIVE NEWS IN
THE JANUARY BUDGET IT'S STILL
HAS SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA -- I WANTED TO TO
TALK NOW ABOUT SOME OF THE THE
HIGHER ED REALLY A PROPOSAL
SO THE ELEMENTS OF THEM PARK
OUR CARS ARE SOLID CERTAINLY
OUR JOB TO ADVOCATE FOR MORE
AND THAT THE BIGGEST ISSUE ON
ON ALWAYS A MINUTE MENTION IS
ACCESS TO FOR EXAMPLE FOR THE
UC AND CSU -- PROPOSALS --
HUNDREDS OF MILLION DOLLARS
OVER FIVE ZILLION COMBINED
FOR FOR THE TWO BUT FOR FOR
EXAMPLE FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AT NOT ONE
ADDITIONAL SLOT FOR CALIFORNIA
KIDS TO GO TO UC I KNOW THE
BUDGET HAS MONEY THAT FUNDS
PRIOR YEAR -- AGREEMENTS BUT
NO ADDITIONAL ACCESS AND THOSE
ARE THE ISSUES ARE CONSTITUENTS
ASK US ABOUT THAT CSU YOU
KNOW WE HAVE I THINK ELEVEN
THOUSAND SLOTS BUT THERE'S
THIRTY THOUSAND QUALIFIED
CSU APPLICANTS THAT HE DID
THAT DON'T GET ACCESS EVERY
YEAR SO THOSE ARE SOME ISSUES
WILL BE TRYING TO WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROPOSAL
VERY -- PLEASED TO SEE THAT
FOR FREE FOR A YEAR TO IN THERE
FOR FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE ONE
KIND OF TWEAK THAT WE WANTED
TO TO PUT ON THE TABLE IS
THERE ARE -- FULL TIME STUDENTS
WHICH BE NOT THE FIRST TIME
BUT BUT ALL IMPROVEMENTS IS
OUR FIRST TIME FOR EXAMPLE YOU
COULD GO MANY COMMITTEE CALL
STUDENTS NOW THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THE GRACE EXPERIENCE WHEN THERE
ARE EIGHTEEN OR NINETEEN THEY
GO WORK FOR A FEW YEARS MAYBE
THEY'LL HAVE LESS THAN SIX OR
TEN UNITS UNDER THEIR BELT AND
THEY GO BACK IN A ROLE FULL
TIME TECHNICALLY THEY'RE NOT
FULL TIME FIRST TIME SO THAT'S
AN ISSUE THAT WE WANT TO TO
CONSIDER WE GO THROUGH THAT THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND LASTLY FOR
THE FOR THE EARLY EDUCATION --
PROPOSAL OF YOU KNOW AS AS OUR
CHAIRMAN SAYS IT IT'S IS GREAT
WE SEE THESE ISSUES IN JANUARY
USUALLY HAVE TO FIGHT TO PUT
THEM ON THE MAP AND SO WHILE
WORK SQUABBLING A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE ELEMENTS THE MONEY
ONE TIME ON GOING YOU KNOW
THERE IS A GREAT APPRECIATION
THAT THE RECOGNITION THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT CALIFORNIA
OUGHT TO BE INVESTING IN THE
LOOK AT THE ISSUES OF THE
DAY WERE TRYING TO TACKLE
WITH ADDRESSING ARE CHEAP
AND GAP ON OUR SCHOOLS --
INTERGENERATIONAL POVERTY
SPECIALLY CHILD POVERTY OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM REALLY
EDUCATION IS A PLACE THAT NO
RESEARCHERS ECONOMIST NOBLE
LAUREATE SAID THAT'S A PLACE
YOU OUGHT TO BE INVESTING SO
THAT WE'RE WE'RE PLEASED BY
THAT ELEMENTS THERE YOU KNOW
WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT YOU
KNOW KIND OF FINE TUNING THAT
THE LONG TERM CREE QUE FOR
ALL PLAN HERE AS WELL SO THAT
WE CAN DO TO INCREASE ACCESS
-- THIS YEAR AND AGAIN NOT
JUST FOR FOR PRE K.
BUT -- ZERO THREE FIVE
-- PROGRAMS BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THAT THE NEED IS
TREMENDOUS THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD
-- THEN THIS RUBIO YES THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
I I ONE ECHO A LOT OF THE
COMMENTS THAT DOCTOR ARAMBULA
MADE HE AND I WORKED VERY
HARD -- ALONG WITH MANY OF
OUR ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES ON
HEALTHCARE ISSUES AND AND AND
THE GOAL OF PROVIDING HEALTH
CARE FOR ALL IN CALIFORNIA SO
I APPLIED -- THE GOVERNOR'S
-- PROPOSALS ARE WE LIVE VERY
MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH HIM I KNOW THAT SOME OF
THE PROPOSALS ARE MERE ACTUALLY
WORK THAT WE HAVE DONE IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND -- BUT HOWEVER THEIR HEARTS
SOME VERY BOLD PROPOSALS THAT
WE HAVE NOT WORKED ON -- IT
TO THAT EXTENT AND I'M VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR GOING
FORWARD -- DO HAVE ONE QUESTION
-- THAT'S REGARDING YOU KNOW
ALL OVER THE YEARS A LOT OF
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN CUT -- AND
SOME OF THE FUNDING HAS NOT
BEEN RESTORED -- I THINK A
PARTICULAR AROUND -- -- WITH
THE SPACE YOU WITH MEDICAL
PROVIDERS OR PROP SIX PROP
FIFTY SIX HELPS TO INCREASE
THEM BY SOME REIMBURSEMENT
BACK TO PROVIDERS BUT THERE
THERE'S THINGS LIKE NON MEDICAL
-- TRANSPORTATION THAT HASN'T
THAT WAS CUT TEN PERCENT IN TWO
THOUSAND LEVINSON NEVER BEEN
RESTORED -- AND OTHER PROVIDERS
AS WELL SO I AM CURIOUS AS TO
IS YOU KNOW IS THAT SOMETHING
THE ADMINISTRATION IS OPEN
TO LOOKING AT IN THE FUTURE
-- AND I SEE WE HAVE SOMEONE
HERE MIGHT BE ABLE TO ANSWER
THAT -- BUT -- AND THAT'S SO
LET HIM ANSWER THE QUESTION
I HAVE A COUPLE OF FOLLOW UP
SALTERTON OVER THAT IT WAS
ANDERSON BERMAN FINANCE SO
YES I MEAN THESE ARE THINGS
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL THE
TIME SO I THINK THAT THE MOST
COMMON YOU KNOW -- ISSUE THAT
WE HEAR ABOUT WHEN IT COMES TO
PROVIDER RATE REDUCTIONS WERE
THE REDUCTIONS UNDER AB NINETY
SEVEN -- THE RECESSIONARY
REDUCTIONS AND SO THE WAY THAT
THOSE REDUCTIONS WORK IS THAT
THEY WERE REDUCTIONS OF UP TO
TEN PERCENT MEETING THAT -- THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN EVALUATE IF
THERE WERE ACCESS CONCERNS WE
CAN REDUCE THE SIZE OF THOSE
REDUCTIONS OR -- CHOOSES STOP
IMPLEMENTING THEM IF THERE WAS
DEMONSTRATED ACCESS CONCERNS
IN FOR OVER TWO THIRDS OF
THOSE REDUCTIONS HAVE EITHER
BEEN ELIMINATED BY LEGISLATIVE
ACTION OR ADMINISTRATIVE ACTION
WHEN -- THERE WAS AN ANALYSIS
THAT THERE WAS AN ACCESS
PROBLEM AND THIS BUDGET -- DOES
A LOT TO INCREASE PROVIDER --
-- PAYMENTS THROUGH PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX AND SO -- CERTAIN
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AS
WE'VE COME OUT OF THE RECESSION
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF WORK IN
THIS AREA TO TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS ARE STILL A FEW THINGS
HAVE NEVER BEEN RESTORED SO
I'M MORE INTERESTED IN YOU KNOW
IS THE ADMINISTRATION OPEN TO
LOOKING AT THOSE THINGS IN THE
IN THE PAST THAT THAT HASN'T
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS HAVE
HAVE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HELP US
IN THAT REGARD ALWAYS ALWAYS
-- OPEN TO THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AS WE HAD WHEN WE RUN DOWN
SOME OF THOSE THINGS IN THE
PAST TWO LEGISLATIVE ACTION
-- AND AND ALSO AT YOU KNOW
US THERE'S ACCESS CONCERNS WE
WANT TO HEAR ABOUT THOSE SO
THAT WE CAN EVALUATE THOSE AS
WELL -- JUST -- YOU KNOW ON --
LAST WEEK -- THE CUT BECAUSE
OUR FAMILY FOUNDATION RELEASED
A POLL THAT LOOKED AT ISSUES
THAT THE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
WANT THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNMENT SALUTE TO WORK ON
AND AND AND IN ORDER OF OF
THAT WERE EDUCATION HEALTHCARE
AND HOUSING AND SO SO I GUESS
THAT I WANTED KUDOS TO THE
ORDER -- THE MINISTRATION FOR
THEIR PROPOSALS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION I WOULD ADD
THAT -- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THAT WE'RE BEGINNING TO
SEE MORE AND MORE OF AS WE
HAVE IT IT ACTUALLY A VERY
APPROPRIATE EMPHASIS ON EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND AND
AND GETTING PEOPLE OFF TO GOOD
START MANY PROGRAMS THAT AFFECT
OUR SENIORS -- -- HAVE HAVE
NOT SEEN THE EMPHASIS THERE
THAT THAT THAT WE ARE THAT
I PERSONALLY THINK THAT THAT
THEY THEY THEY SHOULD HAVE AND
THERE ARE MANY SENIORS WHO ARE
ON THE EDGE OF HOMELESSNESS
-- BECAUSE OF SOME SOME
FEDERAL POLICIES AND AND EVEN
STATE POLICIES THAT THAT THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN PREVIOUSLY ON
THE EDGE OF HOMELESSNESS AND
SO AS WE LOOK AT HOMELESSNESS
AND WE LOOK AT HOUSING WE
REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT ARE
VULNERABLE SENIOR POPULATION
AS WELL BECAUSE IT THEY THEY
ARE NOT AS THEY ARE NOT AS
VOCAL THEY ARE NOT AS MOBILE
OFTENTIMES AND BUT AND AND WE
SHOULD NOT HIDE WE SHOULD NOT
IGNORE THAT AND I HOPE THAT
WHO GOING FOR WE CAN HAVE THE
ANY KNOWLEDGE MEANT OF THAT AS
WELL AND THEN FINALLY -- AS WE
LOOK AT -- -- IN THAT IN THE
KAISER FAMILY FOUNDATION COLE
WAS VERY INTERESTING -- VERY
INTERESTING CYSTATIN STICKS IN
THE MATTER HOW YOU READ THIS
BUT BUT IF YOU LOOK AT -- AND
I CAN'T REMEMBER EXACTLY EXACT
CATEGORIES BUT YOU PUT THE
TOP TWO CATEGORIES OF PEOPLE
CONCERNED ABOUT TOPIC TOGETHER
YET EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA IS VERY
INTERESTED IN MENTAL HEALTH
AND AVAILABILITY OF ACCESS TO
PROVIDERS AND AND ACCESS TO
SERVICES AND SO AS WE LOOK AT
HOUSING AND THE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS -- IS REALLY CRITICAL
THE WE LOOK AT MENTAL HEALTH MY
MY OPINION MENTAL HEALTH PM THE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES SO THAT
THOSE PEOPLE WHO HAVE THESE
CHALLENGES CAN ACTUALLY UTILIZE
THE HOUSING THAT WE HOPE
HOPE TO CREATE AND SO -- THAT
MENTAL HEALTH PICK PEACE HAS
BEEN HAS SOME SOMEWHAT VACCINE
-- BUT THERE IS A HUGE NEED
RECOGNIZED BY A HUGE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS AND I HOPE THAT
I HOPE WE CAN WORK OUR WORK
ON THOSE ISSUES GOING FORWARD
SO AND ONE LAST POINT ON THAT
MENTAL HEALTH IN ADDITION
TO THE PROPOSALS THAT ARE IN
THE BUDGET THE GOVERNOR HAS
COMMITTED TO APPOINTING A VERY
HIGH LEVEL ADVISER TO HIM AND
HIS ADMINISTRATION ON MENTAL
HEALTH SOMEONE WHO IS KNOWN
NATIONALLY AND SO I THINK WE'LL
ALL BE WARNING WHO THAT PERSON
IS VERY SOON BUT I THINK IT'S
SOMEONE WHO CAN HELP ADVANCE
THE AGENDA AND PRIORITIES THAT
YOU DESCRIBED BECAUSE ONE POINT
THAT YOU MAKE WHICH IS SO TRUE
IS FOR A NUMBER OF THESE ISSUES
HIGH HOUSING HOMELESSNESS
WE ALL DRAW A PICTURE IN OUR
HEADS UP WHAT THAT PERSON WAS
AFFECTED MAY LOOK LIKE BUT
IN FACT ALWAYS AFFECTS A MUCH
WIDER SLICE OF THE POPULATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER -- RUBIO THE
MYSTERON LOS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- I WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT -- DISCUSSION
-- NEAR REGARDING THE
REHABILITATION AND EDUCATION OF
INMATES -- YOU MADE A COMMENT
ABOUT INCREASING FUNDING FOR
TIME TO SUPPORT THE TEACHERS
-- TO HELP WITH THE LITERACY
OF THOSE INMATES BUT FROM
WHAT I UNDERSTAND THAT A PART
OF THE ISSUE THE OTHER ISSUE
AND I THINK THIS IS THE MOST
CRITICAL ISSUE IS THE LACK OF
STAFFING WITHIN THOSE THOSE
EDUCATIONAL SETTINGS -- FROM
WHAT I UNDERSTAND SOMETIMES
THERE'S -- ANYWHERE BETWEEN
TEN TO FIFTEEN INMATES PER
ONE TEACHER WHICH IS REALLY
PUTTING THOSE TEACHERS AND
DANGER BUT IT'S NOT JUST WITHIN
THE THE THE TEACHING IT'S ALSO
IN THE WITHIN THE STAFFING OF
THE PRISONS AND SOUL -- I'VE
HEARD SCENARIOS FOR EXAMPLE
THAT SOME OF THE INMATES DON'T
GO TO THOSE CLASSES BECAUSE
THEY'RE AFRAID OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION THEY GET THREATENED
BY OTHER INMATES AND SO SO I
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION
-- INCREASING THE FUNDING FOR
SUPPORT FOR THOSE TEACHERS
BUT I THINK THE BIGGER ISSUE
IS THAT THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
STAFFING TO SUPPORT THOSE
TEACHERS WALL THERE IN THOSE IN
THAT SETTING WITH THOSE INMATES
IS THERE ANY -- -- ANY -- LE
I'VE ARE WE LOOKING INTO THE
STAFFING RACIAL SO THAT WE CAN
SUPPORTERS TEACHERS BECAUSE
FIRST OF ALL IF THE TEACHERS
ARE IN DANGER -- OBVIOUSLY
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DO AN
EFFECTIVE JOB BUT IF THEY'RE
BEING ATTACKED FOR EXAMPLE OR
IF THERE'S NOT ENOUGH STAFFING
WITHIN THE PRISON SYSTEM TO
WHERE THE INMATES ARE NOT
GETTING TO THOSE CLASSES THIS
MONEY IS GREAT BUT IF WE'RE
NOT ACTUALLY -- INCREASING THE
LITERACY OF THESE INMATES HOW
ARE WE GOING TO REHABILITATE
ABSOLUTELY I'LL MAKE ONE POINT
AND THEN TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE AS WELL -- FOR THE
INITIATIVES THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITTEE TO IN THIS BUDGET
THE ADDITIONAL MONEY A STEP FOR
STAFF AND FOR THESE PROGRAMS
BUT IT'S ALSO TO RECRUIT
PEOPLE -- HE WE MIGHT NOT THINK
OF AS TRADITIONAL STAFF SO
OFTEN EVEN OTHER INMATES WHO
CAN SERVICE LITERACY COACHES
THERE'S ANOTHER INITIATIVE
THAT I DIDN'T MENTION IN THE
SHORT PRESENTATION BUT IT'S
THROUGH CAL VOLUNTEERS TO
RECRUIT FORMERLY INCARCERATED
KEEP ALL WHO HAVE TURNED THEIR
LIVES AROUND AND SERVE AS
MENTORS TO PEOPLE WHO ARE STILL
INCARCERATED SO THAT SOME OF
THE WAYS WE CAN LEVERAGE NEW
MODELS BECAUSE WE NOW WITH
STAFFING THERE'S ALWAYS SO MUCH
MORE THAT WE NEED TO DO BUT ON
THAT SHORTAGE THAT YOU DESCRIBE
ALTERNATE OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
THANK YOU MADELINE CLEAN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I JUST
WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT --
STANDARDIZED STOPPING LEVEL
LOOKS AT EACH INSTITUTION
EACH SECURITY LEVEL AND FOR
EACH TYPE OF ACTIVITY AND THE
APPROPRIATE NUMBER OF STAFF
ARE ASSIGNED TO CATCH AREAS
OR -- EDUCATION OR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION OR ANY TYPE
OF REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS OR
JUST IN THE GENERAL SECURITY
SETTING -- SO AT THIS AT
THIS TIME WE HAVEN'T HEARD OF
ANY ISSUES WE DON'T HAVE ANY
PROPOSALS -- AT THIS TIME TO
INCREASE OR CHANGE THE STAFFING
LEVELS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN ESTABLISHED THROUGH
STEP THROUGH THE BLUEPRINT
THROUGH STANDARD AYE STAFFING
LET ME JUST OUTSIDE THERE
HAS BEEN NO COMPLAINTS ABOUT
THE STAFFING LEVELS WITHIN
THE PRISONS -- I WOULD HAVE
TO DO SOME FURTHER RESEARCH
ON THAT BUT AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE -- EACH CLASSROOM HAS
A SPECIFIC CAPACITY FOR EACH
TEACHER AND WE DON'T EXCEED
THAT WE MONITOR -- MONTHLY
-- THROUGH THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF PROGRAMS THAT ARE
OFFERED TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
A TEACHER IS UNAVAILABLE THAT
THE -- THERE THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS DOESN'T EXCEED THAT
THE CORRECT SECURITY LEVELS
OKAY WELL THEN LET ME ASK THE
OTHER -- THE REVERSE QUESTION
DO YOU MONITOR HOW MANY OF
THOSE INMATES ARE ACTUALLY
ATTENDING BECAUSE THAT'S ALSO
AN ISSUE SO WE MAY NOT EXCEED
THE AMOUNT OF OF STUDENTS BUT
IF THEY'RE NOT ATTENDING AT
ALL THEN WE'RE INVESTING MONEY
INTO EMPTY -- CLASSROOMS ARE
NOT THAT -- CAPACITY CLASSROOM
SO IS THERE ANY STUDY TO SEE
HOW MANY INMATES ARE ACTUALLY
ATTENDING BECAUSE OF THE GOAL
IS TO EDUCATE THESE INMATES AND
REHABILITATE THEM SO WHEN THEY
COME OUT -- INTO THE REGULAR
POPULATION THAT THEY'RE THEY AT
LEAST HAVE THE READING SKILLS
THAT YOU MENTIONED EARLIER
SO IS THERE -- ANY WAY OF
TRACKING OR MONITORING -- TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE INMATES
ARE GETTING THE SERVICES THAT
WE ARE SO SUPPOSEDLY PAYING
FOR YES SO THE US DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS RIGHT RULED
REHABILITATION HAS A DASHBOARD
PROGRAM THAT LOOKS EVERY MONTH
AT EVERY INSTITUTION EVERY
TYPE OF -- REHABILITATION
OR EDUCATION PROGRAM OFFERED
IT LOOKS AT THE NUMBER OF
AVAILABLE CAPACITY IN EACH
CLASS BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
TEACHERS ASSIGNED TO THAT CLASS
AND THAT ALSO GOES BACK AND
IT LOOKS AT -- IN ARREARS EACH
MONTH HOW MANY -- STUDENTS OR
SANDERS ATTENDED THOSE CLASSES
TO LOOK AT PARTICIPATION RATES
AND SO THEY ACTUALLY WILL
LOOK AT THE DATA MONTHLY AND
IF THEY FIND AN ANOMALY IN
A CERTAIN AREA THAT SAY THEY
HAVE -- TO TEACHERS AND COULD
HANDLE EIGHTY STUDENTS IN
THAT CLASSROOM BUT ONLY TWENTY
STUDENTS ATTENDED IT MAY HAVE
BEEN FOR SOME OTHER REASON
THAN LACK OF PARTICIPATION
LIKE A LOCK DOWN OR SOME OTHER
EVENT AT THE INSTITUTION THAT
WOULD PREVENT THE OFFENDERS
FROM ATTENDING THE CLASS MIGHT
MONTHLY TRACK OKAY -- IS THERE
A WAY TO TO ACT -- IS THAT
INFORMATION THAT -- ACCESS
ONLINE OR IS THERE A WAY THAT
WE CAN GET THAT INFORMATION
I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S ACCESS
ONLINE BUT I WILL WORK WITH
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS TO
DETERMINE IF THERE'S LIKE A
ROLLED UP SUMMARY BECAUSE IT'S
LIKE SEVERAL HUNDRED PAGES OF
SPREADSHEET THAT WE CAN ROLL
IT UP BY INSTITUTION TO TRY AND
PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF DETAIL
WHAT THEN THEN THAT'S MY WELL
THAT'S KIND OF THE POINT RIGHT
IF YOU HAVE TO GO BACK AND TRY
TO FIGURE THIS OUT THEN THE THE
THE ACCESS TO THAT DATA IS NOT
READILY AVAILABLE AND SO HOW
IS IT THAT I DO HAVE MONTHLY
GOALS TO HAVE -- I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE THE THE -- FORMAT
LOOKS LIKE BUT IF YOU HAVE TO
GO BACK AND LOOK TO THROUGH
TWELVE HUNDRED PAGES THEN HOW
IS IT THAT THERE THAT -- THE
POWERS THAT BE ARE ACCESSING
THAT DATA IF I CAN'T ACCESS
IT IMMEDIATELY SO THAT THEY
DO A ROLLED UP SUMMARIES WHAT
I'M I'D WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CAN PROVIDE SOMETHING
THAT'S EASY FOR YOU TO READ
THAT HAS ALL THE DATA THAT YOU
HAVE I KNOW THAT WE HAVE SEEN
THE MORE DETAILED VERSIONS
BUT I WILL DEFINITELY TO SPEAK
WITH THEM AND TALK ABOUT OF
MORE ACCESSIBLE DATA FOR OKAY
SO I'M WHAT I'LL DO IS -- I
WILL DO MY PART AND I'LL HAVE
MY STAFF REQUEST THAT THOSE
FORMALLY SO IF YOU CAN -- POINT
THAT'S IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT AGAIN I'M
CONCERNED THAT WE HAVE THESE
CLASSES AVAILABLE AND WE'RE
NOT SERVING THE POPULATION
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO THAT
WE WERE PUTTING ON THAT THOSE
TEACHERS IN DANGER AND SOME
OF THE STAFF MEMBERS AND
THEY'RE IN DANGER IF THERE'S
NO ADEQUATE -- -- SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER RAMOS THE
MISTER COOPER AND THEN THIS
WEEKS -- FOR A HOMELESS ON
ATTENTION TO IT
IN A DECEMBER DINO COUNTY
THERE'S -- OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND HOMELESS YOUTH --
THAT ATTEND -- K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS THERE
ALSO EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWO
YEAR OLDS THAT ARE CONSIDERED
HOMELESS YOUTH THAT ARE THERE
TOO SO WITH THIS POPULATION
IS SEEN THE THE FOCUS NOW ON
THE HOMELESSNESS IN GENERAL
-- I THINK LOOKING AT SOME OF
THE SUB POPULATIONS AS FAR AS
TARGETING THE HOMELESS YOUTH
AND WHEN I TALK ABOUT THE
NUMBERS AND SAN BENITO COUNTY
-- THOSE NUMBERS ARE PROBABLY
THE SAME THROUGHOUT SOME OTHER
COUNTIES IN THE AREA SO WE
START TO LOOK AT THOSE THINGS
WE TALK ABOUT CHILD POVERTY
AND WE START TO LOOK AT THE
EXPANDING OF SHELTERS IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING IS THERE A
WAY AND IS THERE ANY MORE FOR
THEIR DIALOGUE THAT WE COULD
HAVE TO START TO FOCUS ON THE
HOMELESS USE SITUATION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S SHELTERS AND
EXPANDING SHELTERS SPECIFICALLY
TO THAT SUB POPULATION THAT'S
THERE I BELIEVE THAT TAPPING
THE HOMELESSNESS ISSUE IS IS
GREAT WE HAVE TO DO THAT BUT
IF WE'RE GOING TO START TO HAVE
SOME RESOLVES THE MEASUREMENTS
TO IT THAT CAN WE START TO
FOCUS ON THE SUBPOPULATIONS
BUT SPECIFICALLY HOMELESS
YOUTH IN A IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA START TO BRING SOME
SOME OF THOSE RESOURCES THERE
I THINK THAT'S A WAY OF BEING
PROACTIVE TO THAT SITUATION AND
I WOULD ENCOURAGE AND I WOULD
BE OPEN TO HAVE ANY FURTHER
DIALOG WITH YOURSELF IN THE
LA OWES OFFICE TO START TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES
ABSOLUTELY I'LL MAKE TWO POINTS
FIRST IS THAT THAT FUNDING THAT
WE PUT OUT FOR HOMELESSNESS
RIGHT NOW IS A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR MARKET AND ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IS
RESERVED FOR THE BIG CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE OTHER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AS WELL
AS THE INCENTIVE PAYMENTS FOR
JURISDICTIONS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING ARE MUCH MORE GENERAL
RIGHT NOW AND SO WE WANT TO
WORK WITH YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'VE GOT OUR METRICS RIGHT
AND THAT WERE NOT FORGETTING
ANYBODY AND MAKING SURE WE
SERVE THE FULL RIGHT AGE RANGE
OF PEOPLE THE SECOND THING IS
IN OTHER PARTS OF OUR BUDGET --
PRETTY GROWING HIGHER EDUCATION
WE DO HAVE SOME FUNDING
IN THERE AS WELL TO HELP
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OR OTHER EMERGENCY
HOUSING SITUATIONS OF COURSE
MANY OF THE PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING LIKELY MAY NOT EVEN
BE IN ROLE THAT YOU SEE OR
CSU OR A COMMUNITY COLLEGE SO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE WANT
TO WORK WITH YOU WITH THANK IS
AN AREA THAT I THINK -- STARTS
IN COMPASS THE THE TRUTH --
SENSE AROUND HOMELESSNESS AND
ALL THE SUB POPULATIONS THAT
ARE AFFECTED THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER COOPER
DISCOURSE ABOUT CANNABIS
ON THE ENFORCEMENT SIDE THE
BUDGET PROPOSES TWO POINT
NINE MILLION DEPARTMENT TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION WHAT
IS THE ENFORCEMENT LOOK LIKE
ON THAT PIECE SO I'M GONNA
TURN THIS OVER TO A COLLEAGUE
OF MINE WHO WILL HOPEFULLY
BE COMING OUT BECAUSE WHEN IT
COMES TO CANNABIS ENFORCEMENT
REVENUE IT'S ALWAYS THE FEAR
HERE THAT NO ONE WILL BUT
WHEN IT COMES TO THAT A LOT
OF THE PROJECTIONS THAT WERE
MAKING AROUND REVENUES ARE
GOING TO BE IN THE WE KNOW
A LOT OF THE REVENUES OF NOT
MATCHED WHAT ALL THIS EXPECTED
AND IT'S STILL RELATIVELY
UNCERTAIN RIGHT COMES TO THAT
SPECIFIC ALLOCATION LET ME
TURN IT OVER KRYSTLE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE -- IT'S GONNA BE
FOR THE DEPARTMENT TAX AND
FEE ADMINISTRATION TO GO
OUT SEND TEAMS OUT MAKE SURE
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE CAMPUS
RETAILERS ARE ACTUALLY ABIDING
BY THE REQUIREMENT TO PAY THE
APPROPRIATE TAXES ESSENTIALLY
WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE DOING
IS THE ISSUE OF THAT IS THE
REVENUES OF FALL SHORT BECAUSE
THE BLACK MARKET STILL THERE
HAPPENED CANNABIS GROW IN
CALIFORNIA THE STATE SO FOR
MOST FOLKS THAT OUR LICENSEES
-- FOLLOWING THE RULES AND AND
PLAYING NO DOING THEIR PART
AND THE ISSUE OF THE FOLKS
THAT AREN'T DOING THAT SO I
GUESS I'M CONFUSED WITH THAT
WITH THOSE PROBLEMS REVENUE
SO WHAT ARE WE CAN DO TO
ADDRESS THE BLACK MARKET ISSUES
WHERE WAS THE PROBLEMS LIE
KERN COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE -- AS AS WAS
POINTED OUT THAT THE NAY
REVISION SHOULD INCLUDE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN ON HOW WE
WILL -- ALLOCATE -- ALLOCATION
THREE PROCEEDS FOR -- THE
CANNABIS TAX FUND SOME OF THOSE
PROGRAMS WELL AND HIT INCLUDE
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITY AROUND
THE LEGAL CULTIVATION AND
POTENTIALLY SOME MONEY TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS -- THE BUDGET ACT
DOES INCLUDE EVERYTHING THAT
WAS AGREED UPON LAST YEAR WHICH
INCLUDES SOUTH OF LEVEL OF
ENFORCEMENT -- -- IN COMPLIANCE
RELATED TO THE REGULATORY
AGENCIES SO CALIFORNIA BERMAN
FOOD AGRICULTURE BEER CANS
CONTROL PUBLIC HEALTH FISH
AND WILDLIFE IN SOME OF THOSE
OTHER AGENCIES VOTERS WERE
A POP SIXTY FOUR IN WITH ITS
HERE IT'S IT'S PERMANENT IF
YOU CAN WORK BUT UNTIL WE TAKE
EFFECTIVE STEPS TO DEAL WITH
THE BLACK MARKET ISSUES NOT
GOING AWAY AND IF I'M REAL
AND I'LL CONTINUE TO THE BLACK
MARKET BECAUSE I'M NOT PAY
TAXES ON THE PLANE EMPLOYMENT
SHARES ANY OF THOSE THINGS SO
THE BLACK MARKET WILL CONTINUE
TO THRIVE SO TO TAKE A LOOK
FORTY HEARING I THOUGHT THAT
YOU GUYS HAVE ON THAT -- AND
THE EARLIER THIS WOMAN FROM LA
TALKED ABOUT -- DJJ GOING AWAY
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GOING AWAY
GOING TO WELL ASIA IS IT HSS
YES -- WILL PROJECTED SAVINGS
WITH THE MOVE SO THAT THIS IS A
NEW PROPOSAL FROM THE GOVERNOR
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO
TO DEVELOP THE PROPOSAL -- WHAT
ONE -- DETERMINE THE PHYSICAL
FACTS ABOUT SOMETHING WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON RIGHT OKAY APPRECIATE THAT
AND THEN TIE HIM TO THE WE
HAVE PROGRAMS IN THE PRISONS
THAT WE NEED -- IS THERE ANY
EVIDENCE OF WHAT PROGRAMS
WORK NOW THAT IS COLLECTED
THAT GOES BACK TO MISS RUBIO
QUESTIONS EARLIER ABOUT THE
READING IN THERE IT'S AMAZING
THESE PROGRAMS A BIT AFFECT FOR
SOME NUMBER OF YEARS NOW YET
THERE ARE NO MEASURES TO TELL
US WHAT IS REALLY EFFECTIVE
-- IT WAS MIND BLOWING HERE
FROM THE MOTLEY EARLIER SHOULD
LOOK AGAIN BUT I LIKE TO
KNOW HOW LONG THESE PROGRAMS
BEEN AFFECT IN HEALTH AND
WE DON'T HAVE ANY METRICS ON
WHAT'S AFFECTING
WAS NOT EFFECTIVE
MATALIN THE CLEAN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- SO THAT MOST OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE OFFERED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION -- THERE'S
-- ACADEMIC PROGRAMS COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL THERAPY THAT HAS
LIKE A ANGER MANAGEMENT IN
CRIMINAL THINKING -- THAT THEIR
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS MANY PROGRAMS AND THEY
ALL -- FOR THE MOST PART USE
EVIDENCE BASED -- PRACTICES IN
THE IN THEIR DEVELOPMENT AND --
IMPLEMENTATION THAT WILL ASSIST
WITH PROVIDING AS OUTCOMES
THE DEPARTMENT ALSO IN THE
PROCESS OF THEY DO AN OUTCOMES
EVALUATION REPORT EVERY YEAR --
THAT ASSIST WITH -- DETERMINE
THE RECIDIVISM RATE -- AND
THERE ARE ALSO SOME PROGRAMS
THAT THEY OFFER THAT ARE NOT
EVIDENCE BASE THERE -- THAT
MORE THEY THEY ALLOW FOR --
INNOVATION WE CALM INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMMING GRANTS THEY DO LIKE
ARTS PAINTING DANCING MUSIC
THERAPY THOSE TYPES OF THINGS
THAT ARE ARE IN THE INSTITUTION
SO THE DEPARTMENT -- DOES
TRACK AND LOOK AT -- LOOKS AT
PARTICIPATION RATES IN IN ALL
OF THESE PROGRAMS AND BASED
ON THE -- -- PARTICIPATION
RATES THAT THEY'VE SEEN
LATELY THAT IT'S DEFINITELY
INCREASE WITH PROPOSITION
FIFTY SEVEN AM BUT ALL OF THAT
WAS FIRST DISSIPATION RISK OF
JUST SHOWING UP JUST SITTING
THERE IN THE CLASS NOT DOING
ANYTHING YOU THE PARTICIPATION
RATES SO THIS PROGRAMS BUT AS
FAR AS RE PROGRAM WHICH WAS
RUBIO REFERENCED EARLIER THAT
PROGRAMS BENEFIT FOR HOW LONG
THE PROGRAM MANY YEARS RIGHT
AT THE ADULT EDUCATION BASED
CHRISTIAN YES SO IT'S IS MIND
BLOWING WE HAVE NO NUMBERS
ON THAT ACTUALLY TO TELL US
IN IN TERMS OF GRADUATION
-- GRATES AND RECEIVING HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMAS -- CALIFORNIA
IS IN WHEN THE TOP FIVE STATES
IN THE COUNTRY IN TERMS OF
GETTING -- GT'S AND HIGH
SCHOOL EQUIVALENCY FOR INMATES
BUT WOULD LIKE TO CONVINCE
IN THE PROGRAMS AND ANY TEST
A RECESSES OF RECIDIVISM FOR
A MINUTE AND WHEN THE BIG
ISSUES OF RECIDIVISM WE KNOW
IT'S FIFTY PERCENT RIGHT NOW
AND THAT'S PER C.
C. R. BUT WHAT'S WHAT'S MORE
TROUBLING IS MOST THE FOLKS
THAT INTO COMING BACK INTO THE
PROGRAMS DON'T COME BACK TO
SEE YOU SEE OUR LEGAL COUNTY
JAILS SWEEPING FOLKS WHO'D
BEEN SENT TO COUNTY JAILS UP
TO FOURTEEN YEARS AND A LOT
OF COUNTY JAILS ARE BUILT TO
REALLY HAVE ROBUST PROGRAMS AND
DON'T HAVE THE FOOTPRINT TO DO
THAT SO WHEN YOU COMBINE CCAR'S
FIFTY PERCENT RECIDIVISM RATE
AND THE COUNTY JAILS RECIDIVISM
RATE I WOULD VENTURE TO SAY
IT'S PROBABLY AT LEAST SEVENTY
PERCENT IF NOT HIGHER BUT THERE
THERE'S NO CONNECTION I HOPE
THE GOVERNOR LOOK INTO THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S UPON WHEN YOU
ARE GETTING A SMALL SNAPSHOT
OF IT LIKE I SAID MOST FOLKS
ARE NOT GOING NEXT A PRISONER
IN COUNTY JAIL BECAUSE I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LA WE DON'T WANT THESE FOLKS
COME BACK WE WILL HAVE THE
BEST AND MOST ROBUST PROGRAMS
POSSIBLE BUT WE REALLY DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S REALLY EFFECTIVE
THAT'S GONNA STOP THESE FOLKS
IN REALLY GIVEN THE THE THE
PRIME OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED
IN LIFE AND AND AND NO ONE
ON I'LL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
NOBODY CAN TELL YOU THAT FROM
CORRECTIONS NOW WILL HAVE
MEETINGS WITH C. C. R.
FIND OUT OR IS FOR SURE STILL
DIDN'T KNOW THAT NO ONE CAPTION
INFORMATION SO HOPEFULLY WITH
THIS NEW GOVERNOR -- IT'S
A FRESH LOOK CLEAN NICE TO
COME IN AND REALLY SEE WHAT
THE EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS ARE
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE'RE NOT
DOING THAT A LOT OF MONEY IS
BEING SPENT LOVE PEOPLE GETTING
PAID BUT IS REALLY HELPING
THE FOLKS AT NEW THE MOST
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER DO SO
TO WORK LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE -- I JUST WANTED TO
KNOW THAT ARE -- OFFICE DID
LOOK INTO ISSUES RELATED
TO IN PRISON REHABILITATION
PROGRAMMING AND RAISED SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT YOU MENTIONED
ABOUT A LACK ABOUT CONTRACTING
I'D BE HAPPY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE FORWARD A COPY OF OUR
REPORT I WOULD ACTUALLY SIT
DOWN WITH YOU ON THAT WOULD
BE GREAT GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR GOOD IN
THIS WHICH WILL JUST ADD ON
VERY QUICKLY ON THE WALL AND
THEN GO TO SOME OF THE WORKS
CHU CHU I AM SORRY TO PRESENT
WHEN AB SEVENTY TWO TWO
FIVE CHIU AYE AYES TWENTY
SEVEN TWO ZERO AB SEVENTY
THREE TWO TWO AYE AYES
TWENTY EIGHT AND THE RULES
ON MANY ROLES CHU CHU I HI
TWENTY SEVEN GREAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THERE ARE A LOT OF EXCITING
THINGS ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ONE OF THINGS I AM
-- EXCITED SEIZE THE PUSH ON
PAID FAMILY LEAVE -- AND I
KNOW HE OUTLINES THE IDEA OF
DOING A TASK FORCE ON THIS
AND OBVIOUSLY PAID LEAVE
IS -- BENEFICIAL MANY WAYS
LOWERS INFANT MORTALITY RATES
INCREASES LIKELIHOOD AND
DURATION OF BREAST FEEDING
REDUCES POST PARTUM DEPRESSION
AND OBVIOUSLY FINANCIAL
SECURITY FOR THE FAMILY --
CAN YOU SAID SOME LIGHT ON
-- ON THE TASK FORCE THAT'S
BEING OUTLINED IN TEN TO LONG
TERM FUNDING AND AND ALSO
THE TASK FORCE WILL LOOK AT
DISPARITIES BETWEEN PAID LEAVE
POLICIES LOW WAGE WORKERS OR
DISPROPORTION WOMEN OF COLOR
-- HAVE LESS ACCESS TO PAY
LEAVE POLICIES VERSUS HIGHER
EARNERS -- AND WILL THE TASK
FORCE LOOK AT THINGS WITH
IT THROUGH AN EQUITY LINES
ABSOLUTELY SO LET ME MAKE THREE
POINTS ABOUT THAT FIRST DAYS
AT THIS IS A BIG PRIORITY FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION AND EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE STILL FIGURING
OUT HOW EXACTLY WE'RE GOING
TO DESIGN IT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE WANTED TO INCLUDE IN
OUR BUDGET BECAUSE WE WANTED
TO MAKE THIS COMMITMENT VERY
CLEAR AND IT COMES FROM THE
GOVERNOR AND IT COMES FROM
THE CHIEF OF STAFF AND A
WEARING WAS DEVOTED HER LIFE
TO EXPANDING FATE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE AND OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
FOR FAMILIES AND KIDS -- THE
SECOND POINT ON THIS TASK FORCE
-- WE'RE WORKING IN THE NEXT
COUPLE MONTHS AND WE'RE HOPING
BY APRIL NAY BY THE SPRING
AS THE NAY REVISED TIMES THAT
WILL HAVE MORE DETAIL ON THE
BEST WAYS IN WHICH THAT COULD
WORK THIS IS NOT YOU KNOW IT'S
LED BY THE ADMINISTRATION BUT
IT'S NOT IT MINISTRATION ON WE
TASK FORCE AND SOMETHING THAT
WE WANT TO WORK WITH MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE SO I KNOW
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE STARTING
TO THINK ABOUT HOW THAT TASK
FORCE WILL OPERATE WITH WHAT
YOU'RE IN PART IN TERMS OF
WHICH POLICIES ARE PASSED THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ITS BUDGET
HAS COMMITTED TO SIX MONTHS
OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE THE SPLIT
BETWEEN TWO PARENTS OR OTHER
FAMILY CAREGIVERS IF IT'S
NOT A TWO PARENT FAMILY AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DESIGN THAT IN A WAY THAT'S
BEST FOR THE CHILD THAT THE
FAMILIES FUNDING LAST AS
WELL AS ENABLING PEOPLE TO GO
BACK TO WORK AND NOT PUTTING
AN UNNECESSARY BURDEN ON
EMPLOYERS AND THE LAST THING
I'LL MENTION WHICH IS MAYBE
THE MOST IMPORTANT POINT WHICH
YOU RAISED ABOUT EQUITY AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE ADDRESS
DISPARITIES I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THIS TASK FORCE
WILL DO IS START TO LOOK AT
SOME OF THE RESULTS SOMEONE
COMING FROM THE MOST RECENT
PAY FAMILY WE BILL THAT WAS
ENACTED BY THE LEGISLATURE
I BELIEVE TWO YEARS AGO OR
WANTED TO AFFECT TWO YEARS AGO
WAS ENACTED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND WHAT THAT BILL DID WAS IT
INCREASE THE -- INCREASED PAID
FAMILY LEAVE ACCESS ACROSS BUT
ESPECIALLY FOR LOW WAGE WORKERS
INCREASED REPLACEMENT RATE
SO SEEING HOW THAT IS GOING
WHETHER TAKE UP IS INCREASING
AND HOW WE HAVE TO FUND THIS
PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
WE EXPANDED TO SIX MONTHS WE
CAN CONTINUE TO INCREASE THAT
REPLACEMENT RATE FOR THE LOWEST
WAGE WORKERS IS A BIG PRIORITY
AND MORE BROADLY WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAMS IT DOESN'T DO MUCH
UNLESS PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF IT SO AS
PART OF OUR PROGRAM WE WANT
TO ADDRESS ANTI DISCRIMINATION
AND RETALIATION PROVISIONS
MAKE SURE THAT IN THE WAY THAT
WE DESIGN A PROGRAM OFTEN THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED THE MOST HELP
AND MOST NEED THE RELIEF TO
BOND WITH THE CHILD ARE THE
ONES WHO FACE THE MOST TERRIERS
TO ACTUALLY TAKING LEAVE EVEN
WHEN THERE'S A HIGHER PLACE
AND RIGHT SO WE WANT TO WORK
WITH YOU IN DECIDING THAT SO
THAT THOSE FOLKS GET ACCESS
TO THE PROGRAM GREAT WILL SIGN
ME UP ONE WORK ON IT THANKS
THANK YOU SEEING ARE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR ACTUALLY ANY
COMMITTEE NUMBERS LET ME JUST
LET ME JUST THINK THIS CHIU
AND ESTHER FEES FOR ANYTHING
-- FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
STATE VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD
TO THE COMING MONTHS AND
-- FOR THE DISCUSSION AND
MADE OVER THIS -- GREAT
BUDGET SUB THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITHOUT WE ARE A CHURCH